salut à tous on est reparti pour un
petit live et du coup ça fait bien
plaisir Souf il s'est passé pas mal de
choses quand j'étais plus aux
commentaires tu vas me faire un petit
récap j'espère ah oui bien entendu je
t'ai envoyé un petit lien d'ailleurs en
privé
[Rires]
donc là on est la ronde 6 et on a eu
hier et d'ailleurs avant-hier à la
grosse surprise de 45 qui qui a perdu
deux parties d'affilée une contre
une contre guéri et une contre Nord
d'hiver
donc vraiment en plus de belles parties
des adversaires de carcène
donc on va voir aujourd'hui si Carlson
arrive à stopper l'hémorragie donc elle
est noire maintenant contre one forest
one forest qui est qui est intéressant
Kevin et d'ailleurs bonne soirée ce qui
n'est pas très très on va dire inspirer
dans ce tournoi il fait pas de très très
bonne partie je sais pas si tu avais
parti d'hier
j'ai regardé plutôt la partie pour
comprendre un petit peu ce qui s'était
ce qui s'était passé parce que la la
défaite de Carlson a double défaite ça
m'a un petit peu choqué dans le sens bon
moi j'adore Magnus comme tu sais on est
un peu fan et c'est surtout ultra rare
qu'il perde
deux fois de suite ça n'arrive jamais en
fait donc je regardais j'ai vu un
article comme quoi mes deux parties
c'est ce qui perdent dans l'année
normalement donc donc je réponds un peu
à côté de ta question je suis désolé je
souffre ça démarre quand même
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai que j'étais
ouais j'étais très surpris très surpris
après est-ce que c'est le manque
d'objectif est-ce que c'est une période
de mes formes est-ce que c'est le
contrecoup d'avoir tout gagné au cheval
du monde
il y a plusieurs explications à cela ou
simplement aussi un manque de réussite
et puis je joue des joueurs très forts
et était moins inspiré tout simplement
moi je mon avis sur la question je j'ai
l'impression ça fait plusieurs jours que
je le dis en fait sur le stream j'ai
l'impression que que Magnus il a un
petit peu relâché en tout cas plus que
d'habitude depuis qu'il a renoncé au
titre de enfin
tu vois depuis qu'il a
renoncer à jouer le match Championnat du
Monde comprenez pas et ben j'ai
l'impression qu'il a la défaite plus tu
vois plus joyeuse et par exemple on l'a
vu analysé
après cette défaite contre Guiri il
avait le sourire à l'analyse et hier il
est encore analysé un petit peu contre
contre
généralement quand il part une partie
ben il disparaît vite de l'échiquier
bien sûr ça fait deux tas filets et puis
en fait il est intéressé il a eu
l'analysé donc en tout cas intéressant
je sais pas vraiment mais je pense qu'il
est plus décontracté par rapport à par
rapport à tout ça si tu veux quoi bien
sûr bien sûr c'est pas mon signe qui
lâche enfin le
sa couronne de champion du monde
effectivement par rapport à son envie de
compétition on peut peut se poser
quelques questions je pense qu'il va
avoir peut-être une période un petit peu
plus difficile par contre il est
tellement dominant malgré ces deux
défaites qu'on va le voir très
prochainement revenir et pourquoi pas
même dans ce tournoi parce que ça reste
un ultra compétiteur même s'il a un
petit peu rigolé j'ai hâte de voir
aujourd'hui demain comment va finir son
âge je le vois pas lâcher toutes les
parties c'est pas possible il y a quand
même un orgueil qui va revenir quoi bah
oui un orgueil les champion du monde
depuis
2009 il me semble
et carlten ben il adore jouer le jeu
aussi suivre un peu les joueurs qui sont
qui sont assez créatifs donc je pense
qu'on va voir ici une partie assez sympa
de la part de valforest et 47
on verra mais je pense ça va être un
beau feu d'artifice et qui veut se faire
tout dépend de si Jordan van forest veut
bloquer aussi Magnus en étant un peu
moins ambitieux que la coupe humain
après faut faire attention il risque
aussi de déjouer on va bien voir tout
dépendra de la réussite de son ouverture
et si sa préparation passe ou s'il est
dans des terrains connus ou inconnus
justement
vent forest c'est pas vraiment le style
de la maison d'essayer de bloquer
quelqu'un
son style c'est plutôt d'essayer de tout
envoyer de faire mal ouais en fait tu
veux s'amuser je pense qu'il veut
s'amuser avant tout
et donc il veut vraiment faire une
partie voilà mais c'est pas un joueur
qui va jouer la nul à tout prix voilà
contre même quand on regarde scène en
plus quand on regarde etc je pense que
je pense qu'il va vouloir essayer de la
gagner donc
elle sera con ce sera cool en tout cas
salut à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
aussi bonjour à tous
et d'ailleurs Kevin hier je j'en parlais
avec Samy parce qu'hier on a eu Samy
commentaire
d'ailleurs aussi Fatou qui est passé
pendant pendant une petite heure et
demie hier ça lui a dû partir
et du coup on a parlé un petit peu de
nos différents Paris tu sais qu'on avait
pris et il est vrai que on n'est pas
forcément très bien on avait notre digne
en plus hier
Ding était pas loin de de de la
correction dans le début de partie c'est
une partie assez compliqué hier de Digne
contre iRig Asie
et derrière la nul assez incroyable à
trouver un registre monstrueux la
répétition et en tout cas bon je pense
quand même guérit en forme
on l'a mis trois et quatre et puis ça
c'est représentatif pour l'instant de ce
qui produit toi tu avais mis à 12 à
torov 3e donc c'est c'est pas mal ouais
c'est ça je l'ai mis 7e mais il reste il
reste comment on dirait-je oui beaucoup
de parties ça peut tourner mais quand
même il y avait quelque chose quelques
petites choses qui étaient bonnes mais
surtout bah on s'attendait pas à ce que
Carlsen soit aussi loin
on pensait que Ding ou Carlson gagnerait
voir un guéri très en forme après ce cas
d'où ça te rend va réussir à tenir son
rythme
c'est pas impossible il y a de grandes
ambitions je pense et il a des grandes
ambitions mais après il manque aussi un
peu d'expérience par rapport par rapport
à d'autres cadors du tournoi donc on va
voir en tout cas tout est possible
encore car en scène est-ce qu'il peut
revenir franchement est-ce que tu le
vois revenir toi dans cet endroit
j'aimerais bien dire oui pour le pour le
spectacle
tout défendent tout dépend de ce qui
fait là dans les deux prochaines rondes
il faut qu'il fasse un et demi minimum
pour se mettre dans des perspectives
ouais vraiment plus intéressantes et ce
qui peut perdre aujourd'hui tu vois ce
qui serait improbable mais bon comment
il va digérer deux défaites de suite
normalement c'est ces joueurs là ultra
compétiteurs ils ont quand même
l'habitude même en speed chas des fois
de revenir de n'importe où sauf donc
j'ai envie de voir normalement il a il a
tout pour pour revenir maintenant il a
la pièce noire il a perdu avec les
pièces blanchir incroyable bon je je
pense que si venez à gagner aujourd'hui
il peut complètement revenir si tu ne
gagne pas aujourd'hui ce sera plus dur
forcément
et dis-toi que moi tu vois moi en tant
que
en tant que que un peu gambleur et ben
j'ai envie de te proposer un autre pari
Kevin et déjà mon poste il était rempli
tout mais
c'est un pari juste toi tu as juste à
dire oui ou non
c'est hyper dangereux déjà en plus tu
m'as l'air bien préparé sur la question
en fait
alors est-ce que
tu penses Queen qui est actuellement 10e
sur 14 peut terminer sur le podium j'ai
envie de dire oui
dans l'absolu il peut largement mais
[Musique]
toi tu dis oui c'est ça
très très souvent quand il quand il
quand il commence mal quand il fait des
erreurs ou quoi généralement tu vois
rarement car c'est vraiment sombré
jusqu'à la fin ça c'est rare et moi je
le vois pire venir en fait
de la gagner bon peut-être pas mais je
suis bien embêté parce que si donc si je
prends le pari non c'est qu'il revient
pas du tout alors je l'ai pris premier
je l'ai mis premier
ah bien joué il y a Tommy qui m'aide
heureusement que Tommy est là Tommy est
là je crois comme toi Tommy
souffait très très bien préparé c'est
une entourloupe
donc
ça va être
ça va être ça va être compliqué je
réfléchis est-ce que il peut largement
revenir en plus hein si je regarde le
classement il y a rien de rien fait je
peux vous montrer le classement le
classement avec pour voir un petit peu
de quoi on parle
donc pour l'instant ml
avec 2 sur 5
deux points sur abdos à torov et qui n'a
jamais gagné il reste 8 rondes et sinon
à vrai dire il a un point de retard sur
carwana donc
c'est pas ça en fait par rapport à Digne
qu'on voyait dans les favoris il est
encore
je dirais pas un niveau mais il est pas
si loin non mais tout dépend de la
partie d'aujourd'hui après il faut être
après il faut être troisième ça veut
dire qu'au départage même si jamais par
exemple il arrive 4e au départage et ben
il a perdu quoi ça c'est 3e 3e
dans ton style ce pari peut-être une
assurance il ne remonte pas non non je
pense que je vais rester
je vais rester sur ce que j'ai dit et
surtout ne pas parier je vais réfléchir
jusqu'à demain demain
il est reparti s'il ne gagne pas
ça sera plus plus compliqué si gagne pas
je suis pas sûr de vouloir mais
justement du coup ça s'intéressera un
peu c'est comme tu me connais je vais
quand même parier quand même mais on
verra
en tout cas c'est hyper c'est sûr que
non
donc là apparemment aujourd'hui vous les
voyez à l'écran donc on a ce qu'est mort
on a dingaragnan on a guéri irrigasi
en fait
15 scène rapport par âme et karwana
contre goutesh dans Google qui a démarré
un tournoi un petit peu de manière
difficile qui aura les Noirs contre
karwana car voilà qui a ça en forme dans
son entier qui joue pas mal
donc on voit qu'il y a eu un des quatre
mais c'est pas vrai c'est la pas jouer
encore ça c'est pas vrai
vous savez que les parties ont quelques
minutes de retard il y a 15 minutes en
fait de voilà les gens sont pas encore
installés encore le public my Carla qui
se baladent et donc en fait des gâte
c'est un couple qui sont en jeu je pense
pour vérifier que les chéquier marche
bien le tactile tout ça la
retransmission mais c'est pas du tout le
coût de la partie devant le Forest alors
ça ça veut pas dire qu'il veut qui
jouera pas des quatre ensemble on en
sait rien mais
mais en tout cas
pas comment c'est ça a pas commencé
encore
salut à toi gris est devenu hollandais
il a toujours été hollandais ouh là là
la caméra qui saute alors oui Kevin la
caméra elle marche chez moi
j'ai compris
et quand je te dire comment quand je
veux dire comment je fais tu vas pas me
croire
je vais te le montrer à la caméra mais
que à toi tu vois les caméras sont là
dans source
en fait bon ben pour aller sur le truc
normal et ben je vais dans
je vais dans ici là
ça c'est celui-là qu'on voit ici tu vois
voilà je suis en mode studio donc
maintenant on va pas en fait et quand la
caméra saute ce qui est le cas des fois
il faut être tout en bas et que
par contre on voit les autres regardez
bien parce que moi je comprenais pas ça
me faisait bugger depuis plusieurs jours
et malheureusement voilà faut revenir un
peu par hasard mais normalement ce qu'il
faut faire c'est que tu fais ça et tu
reviens en fait et c'est une sorte
d'actualisation c'est trop bizarre mais
bon
j'ai fait ça un peu
par tilt l'autre jour parce que rien ne
marchait etc et en fait ça a marché et
du coup maintenant c'est la parade c'est
que dès que
dès que j'ai un problème je fais ça et
ça marche tout le temps maintenant
mais bon du coup
ça me permet de pouvoir
je sais pas ce que c'est la doudoune
peut-être pour la 3e ronde peut-être
pour la troisième ronde normalement
c'est effectivement un sujet important
Néandertal qui nous fait une petite
blague grande forêt risque-t-il de
prendre 20 coups contre Carlson pour
alimenter tu sais
pas mal pas mal vu encore Néandertal
très en forme je lui proposer un petit
seub avant de Forest pour abandonner je
sais pas si
et du coup point ça au niveau des
chouchous mon petit caïmer il est pas
pour l'instant en train de ramener
ça toi en plus non
je veux même pas vu
par victoire du coup il a il a deux
victoires non
mais
il a gagné
tu as raison
donc il est à
3 nuls de gains quoi je te rappelle je
te rappelle qu'il fallait qu'on se fasse
des pronostics à chaque fois
pronostics
à chaque fois donc il y a juste un sub
pour celui qui a le plus de juste
c'est tout
je vais juste mettre la dernière fois
d'ailleurs quand je t'avais laissé ce
dimanche on a fait mal je crois non
c'est ça
on n'avait pas fait je crois on avait
fait je crois qu'on avait fait tu sais
il restait tu es sûr il reste ouais en
fait c'était en garde
moi je me rappelle le rond-parents je
l'avais écrit il restait digne et McDo
il restait Kemer et il fallait toi tu
avais dit nul nul et moi j'avais dit
gain Mag et gain Carsen finalement il y
a une nul digmag
et il y a eu Gan Carlson donc tu as eu
bon le premier j'ai eu bon le deuxième
elle reste était ego c'était égal quoi
donc du coup ça compte pas quoi on va
dire
ok nickel je l'ai pas écrit tu vois
du coup c'est le rond-parents
que 6 tu vois je pense pouvoir on va
voir le petit G4 je sais pas pourquoi
Kevin je sens où Magnus il a une belle
que il a une belle coupe
Magnus Presley une petite coupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
je suis du meilleur Paris le 7 sur dame
C7 x 3 à 6 G4 alors c'est tout à fait
possible ou pas
vite il joue vite là les joueurs
[Musique]
pour l'instant je reste je reste seul
j'essaie de j'essaie de le faire bouger
le petit Kevin il est trop solide quoi
aujourd'hui
je reste déjà non mais je peux me
concentrer déjà sur le fait d'établir
tous les pronos de la journée il faut
que je me mette les choses sous le nez
alors du coup non
non il va jouer il va jouer KS3 à 6 x 3
et G4
là
ça va être à 6 ça va être G4 c'est
typiquement
une
je pense dans les
dans les cordes de grande forêt tout ça
puis on avait vu aussi une partie de
Carson avec les Noirs contre
c'est contre gandelius je crois on avait
vu ça je sais plus
on va le voir de toute façon
j'ai pas été
aujourd'hui je suis imbêtable
voilà tu vois tu aurais pu parler
je me concentre bien là parce que
je sais que tu essaies de me parler pour
toi
le risque était grand en fait tu vois
même
de me faire carotte
OK et du coup
alors si vous demandez ce qu'on fait on
est simplement en train de noter nos
petits pronos vous savez maintenant une
habitude
vous inquiétez pas on arrive tout de
suite
alors
ça ça va ça ça finisse tout j'étais un
peu vite mais bon ok moi j'en ai marre
qu'un seul
qui nous rejoignent
donc du coup OK
[Musique]
petite ligne avec français 6
on est bien ça se souffle
pas plus que toi
et comme je sais pas comment tu la
connais
il me reste un truc
bon j'ai mis j'ai mis 4 résultats
victoire Ding
guérir
on sent qu'il veut parier pour demain ok
j'ai mis pareil
rapport
ok donc du coup alors qu'avez les
Français 6 du coup jouer par contre
forest il me semble Kevin que
généralement on fait dame prend je suis
pas
non en fait Arnaud Arnaud c'est pas
qu'il a baissé dans mon estime c'est que
moi j'ai un petit poulain cette fois-ci
c'est c'est Abdou et du coup je dois je
gagne un seul par victoire
du coup
j'ai décidé de parier sur le poulain
aujourd'hui et quand les deux je vois
ensemble c'est toujours compliqué
et oui est-ce qu'on a des caméras
spécifiques du coup genre oui oui
j'ai pas préparé mon petit post-it mais
je sais ouais
c'était Bruno qui nous fait remarquer si
on s'intéresse à la gestuelle des
photographes du couloir central là quand
même pas vraiment utile sinon non c'est
bon
vous inquiétez pas je vais vous changer
ça en fait j'ai juste vous dire
cet après-midi dès que tu vois quelque
chose dès que tu sens quelque chose dès
que tu vois qu'on a un oubli parce que
souvent les caméras faut les mettre
manuellement donc si tu as une petite
demande puis les autres aussi et en plus
c'est pas moi qui les gère c'est c'est
Stéphane donc du coup ça sera content de
le faire mais prochainement ça changera
à Stéphane
de voir un peu
c'est moi juste une petite minute
parce que
ça peut être un peu un peu trop rapide
[Musique]
oui en tout cas cavalier français si
cela intervient très tôt
et
dans sa famille oui dame français 6 dans
d'autres on voit des princesses 5
et
et si tu veux même la B prend ceci ça
grille des 5 à du sens sauf qu'on a déjà
perdu pas mal de temps en terme de
développement faut être F8 et cavaliers
G8 qui sont sous développés donc ça
pourrait être un peu risqué de jouer BPR
français pour ouvrir au centre et
normalement sur les baies français la
réaction clé c'est de jouer E5 avec les
Blancs ce qui n'est pas possible ici là
il y a un choix assez
intéressant si vous voulez en termes de
structure d'option
on peut on peut quasiment jouer toutes
les structures après théoriquement il
doit y avoir
il doit y avoir comment dirais-je des
lignes qui sont des choix qui sont
meilleures que d'autres mais en tout cas
là de mon point de vue en tout cas
stratégiquement parlant sans rentrer
dans la théorie pure tous les décisions
ont du sens ont du sens si on fait d'un
français aussi si on joue plutôt pour B5
fou B7 il va falloir s'occuper quand
même du foot C8 si on fait des processus
on joue pour E5
et si on fait B prend ceci on accepte
que le foot C8 soit mauvais on joue des
5 au centre en tout cas vous voyez que
la pire pièce celle qui va avoir le plus
de mal à se développer c'est le fousser
8 donc faut déjà avoir à l'esprit de
trouver quel est son meilleur
développement quand vous avez une
mauvaise pièce c'est généralement par
elle que vous devez commencer dans le
développement
sauf si avec les autres pièces qui
peuvent véritablement bien se développer
vous avez une opportunité extraordinaire
sinon
occupez-vous plutôt de vos mauvaises
pièces
sinon si vous ne faites pas ça ben le
problème va grossir donc vous êtes un
petit peu le médecin de votre position
et il faut aller il faut aller vite sur
le sujet
voilà voilà
du coup
est-ce que tu es dans tes pronoms
en train de en fait vu que j'ai 18
caméras je marque tout à la main savoir
quoi et quoi comme ça au moins
[Musique]
je pourrais naviguer plus facilement
entre les caméras sans sans avoir à
chercher à chaque fois après c'est bien
que tu fasses pas un truc trop trop bien
parce que sinon après quand je vais
prendre la main sur le sujet ça risque
de se voir
regarde ce que j'ai fait je te montre ce
que je fais regarde la caméra
c'est juste écrit
la 1 c'est bon de Forest la 2 c'est
rapport tac tu vois comme ça après je
m'invite dans tous les caméras et je
sais qui est qui juste
le stream se professionnalisme c'est une
régie à toi tout seul stouf est-ce que
vous voulez voir comme la caméra de
Carlson ouais Bruno je pense qu'il
l'attend sinon il va te remettre une
remarque en responsable caméra de
l'après-midi il va être obligé il va
être obligé de te rappeler à l'ordre
il a une belle petite petite
coiffure je pense qu'on va l'appeler on
va l'appeler Magnus Presley
je sais pas si vous le voyez
est-ce que vous le voyez du coup je l'ai
mis en grand juste pour que si bien le
voir
donc
tu as raison je parle du foot C8 le
fouet F8 il peut sortir très facilement
de même que le cavalier G8 pour
l'instant il y a pas de risque énorme au
centre à part si tu joues branchés des 5
mais sinon on peut pas ouvrir tout le
centre rapidement donc bon je suis
pressé mais c'est toujours Latif j'ai
besoin de de pas me faire coincer le fou
c'est 8
très clairement et si je joue d'un
Français 6 B 5 par exemple
mais une pression sur sur 4 un nom d'un
Français 6 B 5 il y aura toujours les
schémas F3 E5 fois F3 donc faudra faire
attention mais
en fait un plan de blanc aussi ça peut
être le petit roc taureau
en fait les idées
que très souvent en fait on va tout
droit comme je l'ai dit il faut F3 il y
a un vis-à-vis et même des fois il y a
même du E5 pour contrôler un peu le gaz
noir ici mettre un fou un cavale bon
venir sur ces cases là pour contrôler
mes gasois et il y a aussi une idée des
fois de cavalier 5 qui peut être
intéressantes à base depuis on prend
puis on prend et ouvrir la position ça
c'est un cahier 5 c'est vraiment un
thème qui est hyper thématique dans
toutes les positions de Sienne
donc avoir
c'est un coup mécanique stuff sur B5 des
noirs
et du coup là ça autorise B prend C6
qui pouvait être joué la problématique
sur B prend ceci c'est que on est très
mal développé avec la dame en C7 donc
c'était un petit peu c'est un petit peu
chaud de le jouer
et après il y avait des lignes comme ça
aussi avec un processus
donc là c'est un petit peu différent du
coup tu penses qu'il peut jouer à 4 non
cette position
je pense qu'il va juste le petit rock et
je descends
qui passe par recette des fois aussi je
crois
Kevin pour pour justement laisser enfin
pour pas se prendre E5 très souvent qui
avait la 5 c'est une idée pour les
blancs donc là ici je suis pas sûr que
je pense ça l'a pas mal mais de manière
générale le café va souvent sept pardon
plutôt que que F-16
est-ce que tu veux qu'on fasse un petit
tour de salle
ouvert
donc on va voir du coup stocker donc ce
gamer c'est une espagnole
une Espagnole voilà pour l'instant
c'est intéressant structurellement quand
même ce qui s'est passé
donc là c'est vraiment de l'architecte
B5 B3 et les thèmes avec A4 pour éviter
les valeurs les compagnie donc c'est
c'est plus marginal mais on risque pas
de se faire attaquer à 5 très
intéressantes en termes de structure qui
permet d'empêcher à 5 baignoires et de
venir plus tard essayer d'affaiblir et
croquer ce petit pion en B4 est assis
sont toujours faibles
maintenant faut faire toujours attention
garder un oeil sur le pion en A5 aussi
avec les noirs
ok ben en tout cas pour l'instant il se
passe pas grand chose
donc ça va
alors jinga rognon c'est une italienne
très classique
Carrefour un carrefour on va regarder
donc italienne que ça tout le monde
connaît qui avait 6 D3 je joue très peu
italienne classique
c'est pas un coup qu'on voit souvent je
crois Kevin non bah je vous avais vu
commenter avec Mathieu une partie où il
y avait la thématique à 5 beaucoup plus
classique maintenant
disons que là la problématique c'est que
l'expansion à l'aide voilà c'est ça du
coup
c'est assez facile à comprendre ces
histoires là les Noirs empêchent
l'expansion au centre parce qu'en
pratique quand les blancs font BK c'est
quand même assez pénible
et du coup
il laisse rebeccadre mais j'imagine sur
B4 un moyen de vouloir jouer à 5 pour
pour casser un peu tout ça je pense
je suis pas sûr que ça marche ici sauf
il faudrait voir des cinq B4 D5 c'est
assez thématique
tu prends
cavalier prend et sur B5 si tu le joues
pour gagner le pion je peux jouer
cavalier A5 je crois dans ce type de
position
et c'est pas du tout clair
ok je perds l'option central mais les
blancs ils ont fait un peu n'importe
quoi en terme de jeu de pièces tu vois
donc c'est compliqué je crois que je
peux peut-être bouffer ces quatre carrés
carrément
mais en tout cas en tout cas c'est
vraiment pas clair cette position
puisque la structure vous très bizarre
il y a la paire de fou qui est qui est
récupérée donc elle est très très
complexe cette position
en tout cas c'est intéressant c'est un
thème que je connais sur B4 on réagi par
D5 en tant que réaction centrale en même
temps que je connais mais en fait que
tout le monde connaît
mais c'est assez rigolo à voir
ok
donc faut savoir que guéri on sait qu'il
est souvent sur l'as déjà vu sur chaise
bas India Giri qui qui est très copain
avec pas mal d'Indiens comme visite
comme meregasi comme tout ça donc je
pense quand même guérite travail aussi
avec avec des joueurs là-bas c'est
possible donc ça a commencé par une
Anglaise qui s'est transformée
finalement en D4 C4 donc c'est un c'est
pas un gamme refuser mais une un petit
triangle en fait si vous voulez pour
l'instant donc c'est une semi slave on
appelle ça le petit triangle parce que
là les Blancs avaient l'opportunité de
jouer pour 4
normalement l'ordre de coups préférés
des Noirs c'est cavaliers F6 pour pour
empêcher cela et après je sois C6 soit
aussi pour retomber dans la semi mais
normalement il l'empêche ça c'est très
chaud là il est des ventes avec des
cadres voilà et c'est le gros bordel
c'est pour ça qu'un certain élèves dans
cette position au lieu de jouer fouder 2
la grosse variante côté en train de
montrer il y a ksc-3 qui est intéressant
aussi mais ça c'est bien ce que tu
montres c'est très intéressant vous
voyez donc là les Blancs ont sacrifié un
pion comme la montre c'est un Gambie en
fait et on a tous les cases noires mais
c'est ultra chaud d'ailleurs je
recommande un peu d'amateurs de jouer ça
avec les Noirs parce que on est quand
même sous pression d'entrée
au niveau ils l'ont beaucoup bossé bon
donc du coup bon c'est complètement
jouable mais ici
pour retomber je l'ai vu dans le chat
quelqu'un nous en a parlé tout à l'heure
de la salle de meyranc classique donc là
des princes et 4 il faut prendre ces
quatre ça joue depuis très longtemps
pour provoquer le fou en C4 et mettre B5
A6 donc du grand classique E4 T5 des 5
donc ça je crois que c'est la TAG
Reynolds
du coup il y avait aussi E5 avec les
blancs avec des ventes extrêmement
compliquées
5 c'est prendre des cartes et ses
cavaliers prend B5 je crois la théorie
bon c'est vraiment quand je vous dis que
c'est compliqué
voilà il y a tout en prise du coup voilà
il faut garder
faudra garder tout ça plus plus
longuement
vous voyez on peut prendre en B5 parce
qu'elle va dire FC en l'air etc etc bon
peu un peu importe en tout cas sont des
variantes qui ont été ultra théorisés et
le coup de D5 c'est le coup le plus aigu
et en fait ce qui est assez marrant
parce que je me rappelle avoir étudié
cette position sauf sur C4 donc fous ces
deux qui a été joué
le bon coup c'est dames cs7 et on laisse
les blancs éventuellement prendre le 6
ce qui est assez choquant tu vois sauf
moi j'avais étudié cette position tous
les joueurs qu'il ajoute depuis
longtemps je joue cette position ça fait
bizarre un peu le pion ici en fait qui
contrôle des cases clés et le fait
d'avoir joué C4 tu as tout tes pièces
qui passent par ces 5 dont le full
cavalier donc on a pas de problème sur
le 6
ce qui est dur à attaquer quand même
défendre
et OK
qu'on a quand même tendance à préférer
les blancs dans celle-là enfin en termes
de jeu j'aime bien les blancs tu as
l'impression que tu peux attaquer un peu
plus
je sais que c'est ultra théorique
ouais de toute façon les blancs sont
toujours mieux quand on respecte la
théorie mais c'est hyper chaud
c'est hyper chaud ça te position ok tu
vois tu vois que
qui généralement quand il connaît bien
etc il veut tout tempo là il réfléchit
quand même pas mal ça veut dire que
peut-être qu'il est pas si bien préparé
que ça dans cette position
et
guéri ben il a une heure 45 à la pendule
on commence avec 1h40 et
Guiri qui d'ailleurs qui perd en forme
un instant moi donc vraiment intéressant
si guéritent
que j'ai pas regardé mais j'ai envie
pour une fois parce que là
pendant ce temps là je vais je vais voir
si on a d'autres d'autres positions
intéressantes on a Abdou contre contre
Prague donc c'est une espagnole
avec un 6 et cavalier 6 ans celle-là et
qu'elle va les prendre un cadre donc ça
c'est hyper connu aussi hyper populaire
pardon
j'ai parti 2012 sur le sujet tu vois ce
qu'ils ont trouvé c'est pour ça
OK
donc là il y avait des cadres B5 D5 pro
c'est aussi hyper hyper connu hyper
théorique il faut 3 fausses
qui contrôle la case des 4
non mais cette tour Eiffel
ok pour pour les Noirs mais ça joue pas
beaucoup
pour l'instant donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut
continuer à l'attaque peut-être cavalier
peut-être tourner un cavalier 5
on va mettre la pression
et voir un petit peu peut-être un
tournoi qui avait les F1 que j'ai 3M
derrière pour faire bloquer un petit peu
ce petit pion des cadres bloquer un peu
les pièces les pièces noires
OK
position
qui est pas inconnu pour les joueurs
pour l'instant parce que c'est normal
ok avant de Forrest Carlson on a vu tout
à l'heure rapidement donc il est à jouer
avec B5 comme on l'avait dit
donc OK
rapport à maxoo
donc
hop
c'est cool ça
un terme prend des quatre cinq ça je
connais bien ça
trois cavaliers c'est 6 Etam des trois
généralement
il y a même des variantes avec Dame E3
mais sans le cavalier c'est trois aussi
dans ces positions là avec Kaïs et trois
grands rock on peut aussi jouer il y a
plusieurs façons de jouer quoi il y a en
fait avant c'était tout le temps fou B5
comme tu l'as dit stouf et maintenant
ils ont trouvé des petits des petits
sous système
[Musique]
et moi j'avais déjà joué sa position là
avec ça et on va jouer pour qu'elle en
fait un jour
et
d'ailleurs là ici sur sur ici
généralement c'est le grand coup c'est
c'est fou B5 full D7 et là il faut
prendre je sais ce qui est qui est un
des grands coups théoriques et surtout
prends bon je fou gs5 pour éviter j'ai 6
justement parce que sur G6
et la structure elle est vraiment
complètement
ignoble
en prime voilà donc du coup je voulais 5
c'est le précis et après aussi si on
joue petit rock ou grand rock deux coups
sont possibles et on joue pour des trois
quai des quatre souvent
les noirs on a perdu fou mais les blancs
l'avancent de développement et
l'objectif de D6 on a le petit son petit
aigle noir
et il y a aussi une position
intéressante avec fou DS7 c'est Dame des
trois
ici de dire en fait tu as le temps de de
jouer ça et là d'ailleurs j'avais une
petite un petit piège c'est une
préparation que je te montre là donc je
t'apprends
la parler de deux choses différentes
soit une préparation soit un petit piège
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose mais
en fait parce que c'est quasiment
nouveauté en fait d'accord si en
mangeant ceci et ici sur E6 je crois
qu'on joue G5 et surtout 7 en rock alors
cette position bah en fait tu veux quoi
parce que tu bon moi je me la souffrance
et éventuellement on s'en fout prend
large peut-être manger des sistes tu
vois bien sûr
c'est pas forcément facile j'ai cavalier
des cas F4 F5 vous tapez sur le petit
pion aussi
et en fait c'est pas simple vraiment
savoir comment on réagir avec les Noirs
ici et sur un coup qui a l'air quand
même assez logique dans ma 5 c'est un
coup qu'on dirait pas que c'est une
grosse faute enfin
j'étais en train de regarder j'étais
regarder en train de regarder à 6 tout
simplement tu vois pour essayer de
manger mais du coup tu n'as pas un petit
temps par rapport à ce que je voulais
faire en fait à la base dans la ligne
théorique je prends ceci directement
tu fais assise bah je mange et puis je
me dis bah écoute j'ai gagné un temps
par rapport à la ligne parce que si
c'est pas forcément un coup utile
donc voilà après tu peux ok tu peux
faire plein de choses mais
une ligne qui qui que je connaissais il
y avait E5 non c'est ça que j'ai enfin
bon j'ai eu peur sur Rock 5 et je sais
plus exactement
je le cavalier en fait tout simplement
bah je vais manger là
puis je mange là du pion ou la dame et
puis bah j'ai déjà gagné quoi
si tu manges en 5 du pion et ben je
mange un M6
et du coup le fou des 7 sera plus
défendu par le cavalier donc du coup
c'est perdu
si tu manges du cavalier je crois que
c'est cavalier prend il me semble et si
tu manges du coup du pion ici
tu manges intermédiaire en B5 je crois
que je prends de la dame
et du coup
[Musique]
quand tu vas manger là je fais échec et
je mange là
donc en gros on sent que c'est fin que
c'est pas un bon coup puis tu vois c'est
vraiment pas mal d'idées intéressantes
dans cette là tu vois que tu es pas
obligé de faire [ __ ] France 6 directs
quand même le Dame des trois bref donc
d'un des trois ici avant de jouer le
foot bon moi je connais pas pour du coup
cette position parce que comme tu l'as
dit ça arrive de faire de te faire des
dames 3 ou dame D3 pour plus tard je
sais 4 mais là du coup
j'ai un cavalier en C3 qui empêche de
faire ses cadres
OK
donc là faut prendre une décision mine
de rien c'est pas évident généralement
on va manger en dessin
c'est logique vous voyez la menace
de cette présentation c'est que j'ai un
pion qui va manger on prend et cavalier
E5 semble logique en tout cas pour mais
le plan en fait des blancs
d'essayer de ramener une tour sur la
colonne et taper sur le pion 7
sur le long terme genre
petit
voir si je peux attaquer
ici comme ça il y a eu fou aussi c'est
la laisser du coup la prise en
ça c'est marrant parce que du coup et
puis on sait ce qui va être en grosse
difficulté salut François alors j'ai vu
ton message je l'ai pas encore ouvert
mais je m'attends au pire
peut-être sa cavalier prend pion prend
des cinq
à tous tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
cavalier prend ici
puis on prend et si je le fou qui bouge
des cinq
j'y vais ça a l'air bien parce que
qui active quasiment active ici et j'ai
aussi le roi blanc qui est encore ici un
noir l'avantage de développement donc en
fait on va ouvrir la position sur le roi
c'est tout à fait logique ouais j'aime
bien cette ligne
[Musique]
bon c'est un petit pressing blanc mais
pas grand chose quoi
plus agréable quand même à jouer
ok on continue notre petite notre petit
tour
il manquait plus que voilà Google
pour voir la suite
je crois que j'ai fait une bêtise
donc du coup
un petit
petite petit Gambie dame ragozine qu'on
voit
4 tamac
c'est
assez populaire
3 bah on a vu la partie de Carlson
du coup les wests ont pas le vent en
poupe donc dès le troisième coup en fait
maintenant les joueurs qui jouent à
Nimzo décident de retomber dans le
gambidam quoi
on le voit vraiment très très
régulièrement et on a eu un
gangnamagotine avec damacat pour forcer
cavalier C6
comme ça le pion C7 ne veut plus aller
en C5
voilà
et après on joue simple
on sort les pièces maintenant avec avec
les blancs
tout à fait naturellement donc fouder 2
sur
sur cavalier 7 c'est pour pouvoir
reprendre du Fou en C3
mon vol c'est assez bizarre parce que je
vois dans une semaine généralement c'est
il t'envoie ça là-bas non
j'ai peur
ça c'est
je suis capable de mettre tromper de
date lors de mes vols je regarde ce que
j'ai foutu
qui a lieu
après cavalier 7 fous des deux bécis
8 ok
le fou noir n'avait pas de cases il faut
à 6
voici ce qui paraît naturel parce qu'en
cas de prise en dessin les fous blanc
s'échangent et le fou blanc C3 c'est le
plus triste des fous donc ça serait une
bonne affaire pour les Noirs donc là
l'excellent B3 joué par Fabiano Carola
et maintenant c'est compliqué parce que
les Blancs le centre et si on joue pour
C5 ça ouvre toutes les cases noires
donc à la fois il va falloir trouver
quelque chose j'aime pas trop la
position noire je sais pas trop comment
la
comment jouer la jouer bah oui parce que
si j'ai passé 5
il y aura une amélioration assez facile
pour les
pour les blancs donc est-ce que je vais
passer par cavalier E4 peut-être pour
faire quelque chose
est possible ou pas
oui mais alors faut faire attention
cavalier F5 il y a peut-être c'est
prendre des 5 dans certains cas sauf qui
empêche eux prend des cinq on fera
garder les cavaliers
et du coup
cavalier F5 faut regarder aussi fou B4
les deux sont intéressants peut cumuler
les deux ouais j'ai envie de jouer pour
prise des cinq si tu veux
[Musique]
ouais ça serait pas une bonne nouvelle
de reprendre une pièce quand même
un peu comme tu l'indique cavalier F5 a
du sens pour essayer de faire un truc un
peu plus
dynamique parce que sur le long terme
cette position elle est pas très saine
avec les noirs
ça veut pas être de l'impro je pense je
pense que blocage quand même il sait et
c'est ce qui fait
c'est pas très inspirant
on a un truc assez original de de gamer
qui tourne en B5 qui sont arrivés donc
on est arrivé là on s'est arrêté là
il y a eu des quatre c'est arrêté ici et
du coup sur D4 il y a eu cavalier prend
un peu moche et du coup
tourbérée
surtout qu'on a besoin de ça sauf pour
le cavalier en C7 ouais déjà hein
mais aussi avec ces 5 c'est de bouger la
dame pour faire comprendre à 5 avec la
dame vous voyez qui qui défendra la case
à 5 une fois que j'aurai juste 5 quoi
tant que j'ai pas joué ce 5 je peux pas
manger ici donc du coup intéressant
mais il y a un gros retard de
développement chez les Noirs
[Musique]
c'est dans l'esprit c'est un Gambie du
coup voilà c'est 5
et là je sais pas où mettre la dame
ok bon des trois du coup ah oui
en tout cas il joue très très vite
caméra il est préparé hein
si vous voulez
qui est mort qui
est de tout simple en fait là où les
joueurs sont très forts on voit où
est-ce les hommes moi ce qui m'embêtait
c'est d'avoir le pion à 6 de moins
c'est un pion quoi et ouais je joue ça
tranquille je suis pas sûr qu'ils
connaissent par cœur quand même puisque
Kemer a l'air de bien mieux connaître il
serait que l'option est assis avant
qu'il soit valorisé va prendre du temps
les pièces noires de caméra sont moches
donc il y va franco on laisse les saut
avec ce cavalier qui peut arriver en E4
ou un F3 surtout en E4 sans doute pour
aller vers G5 soit avec le fou soit avec
le
partie déjà
sans bien ici
il va devoir jouer des coupes par
lui-même la position n'est pas si facile
je pense
parce que là je pense que si vous voulez
vu son temps il a pas joué beaucoup par
lui-même si la partie elle commence
maintenant pour lui je trouve que c'est
pas facile je trouve
non je pense qu'il va falloir à peu près
quand même quand là c'est les pièces je
pense qu'il faut savoir ce qui quel est
son plan et comment il doit jouer
il a mangé un pion certes
mais c'est vrai que
il fait qu'à eux aussi je pense là ça
va te prendre tous les pièces dans la
tronche j'aime pas du tout cette pause
j'aime pas du tout non plus ah ok
d'accord
et du coup il y aurait dû prendre le 5
tu peux pas avoir découvertes
par défaut il va falloir ou alors un
petit dame G3 et aussi je pense pas
qu'on soit vraiment là pour aller manger
les petits pions Kevin tu me diras je
l'avais oublié sauf pour être tout à
fait franc mais
pour venir avec un beau cavalier un fou
ici bloqué un peu la case des 6
c'est pas bête mais ça me fait un peu
mal au cœur ils ont deux bonnes idées
d'âme G3 pour mettre le pressing à
cavalier E4 par la suite
et donc j'ai trois peut-être qu'il faut
que je fasse roche suite à 6
faut que je fasse quelque chose donc
j'ai envie de faire quelque chose parce
que sinon ou alors
j'ai peur
ça me fait vraiment très peur
c'est le genre de position que j'aime
pas non si je voulais si c'est au coup
d'avant mais même j'ai pas envie de
faire ça je trouve ma position peut-être
que je joue fou B7 alors sauf pour
t'empêcher non avant
sur dame G3
crouter le cavalier E4 qui viendrait en
E4
pour éliminer du monde
et ce cavalier 7
tu manques peut-être plus de pièces je
pense que c'est la bonne la bonne façon
de jouer avec les noirs
mais c'est chaud
alors visiblement G6 c'est un bon
gruyère parce qu'il y a X6 je pensais
cavalier ça suffisait mais
mais peut-être pas on a un peu sur la
défensive
s'il n'y avait pas de menace est-ce
qu'on pouvait percer
est-ce qu'on a le droit de défis
autrement sauf pour essayer de réagir au
centre
en tout cas c'est beaucoup de coups il
est en train de bien connaitre parce que
très clairement c'est c'est plus dur à
trouver côté noir les coups avec les
blancs des roules c'est facile on a
plein
d'idées salut patoche salut Pékin
bonjour à tous
bienvenue à tous à tous ceux qui
arrivent sur le stream
est moche pour l'instant donc il faut on
a beau avoir un pion de plus on le
protège pas trop donc
c'est une extrémiste
malheureusement
quand tu veux manger
elle est assez friable mais on a trouvé
en fait je pense qu'il va falloir jouer
pour des six et le fouet 8 en B7 pour
croquer le cavalier 4 mais il a fallu
s'y reprendre à plusieurs fois mine de
rien pour pour trouver le bon tempo
autour de cela
alors Guiri on voit une position sur
guéri
où il y a eu un rock des Noirs ouais
c'est donc
ici c'est normal dans ces positions ça
existe
il y a les mêmes thématiques un peu
partout de toute façon c'est comme dans
le Gambie bodinique les positions sont
hallucinantes donc ça
prouve pas ça stupide même si leur dit
un patron on voit que c'est quand même
dans l'esprit avec le fou baisser de
braquer sur le petit Roc Blanc
en fait qui sont qui sont assez
actifs au final je peux virer un peu les
pièces tout ça
c'est un contre-exemple de ce qu'il faut
montrer à niveau amateur parce
qu'effectivement c'est quand même sur un
fil que ça joue on est d'accord avec
point je suis sûr qu'il y aura des
remarques en ce sens
ça fait peur vous voyez tous les pions
sont avancés le roi et tout seul
derrière ça fait peur mais d'un autre
côté si on peut imaginer le roi noir
juste à la place
partir
en petit rock avec la paire de fou qui
est braqué sur le roi là ça a fait un
peu peur aussi complètement
je pense que je préfère faire un rock
ici
donc cinq
c'est la partie
salut
sur un fou E4 peut-être du cavalier V6
pour venir installer un petit cavalier
en
dessin
ok on est à peu près sûr que les blancs
sont mieux parce que le roi blanc est
beaucoup plus stable mais c'est pas si
facile de percer peut-être
il va falloir mettre en place l'idée B3
dans de bonnes conditions alors je tiens
j'ai une idée stuff ça ne marche pas et
j'aimerais bien faire allez je vais je
vais faire un cours
rigolo juste pour l'exemple
dans ces positions sauf on peut imaginer
un coup très créa donc qui dit créa sans
doute mauvais c'est B4 pour faire A4
claque un pion et je fais un câble dans
la foulée
un petit peu garder la position fermée
et du coup
comme dans la partie d'ailleurs trouve
de
du petit gamer
et rigolo c'est que souvent bon faut
prendre B4 imaginons et l'idée c'est de
fixer et d'avoir un carte
malheureusement il a fou ces trois et du
coup tous ces trois B4 et du coup ça
tient pas en tout cas c'est juste pour
montrer l'exemple de la fixation
s'il y avait pas fou ces trois ce serait
cohérent là comme il a fout ces trois
bons c'est différent c'est d'ouvrir les
colonnes donc là on a recomposé donc un
écran composé le roi noir qui est déjà
un petit peu ouvert on a envie de de
d'échanger en fait enfin de d'ouvrir les
colonnes A et B donc même au prix d'un
pion c'est c'est toujours intéressant de
faire ça genre là par exemple
ce serait intéressant et du coup dans la
séquence de la partie peut-être qu'on
peut faire A4 B4 A5 c'est pas justement
je me posais la question de comment
avancer ici
pour venir affaiblira plus tard ouais
c'est ça j'aimerais bien passer
peut-être le fond à quatre à un moment
toujours toujours chaud il y avait B3
fou BK aussi qui me plaisait
il y a beaucoup de coups candidats des
deux côtés
en tout cas c'est pas facile pour les
deux joueurs instauff on voit que c'est
une position complètement atypique donc
dès qu'on joue un coup ça peut beaucoup
plus virevolter
j'aime bien les blancs j'aime beaucoup
les blancs et je pense que Guiri
il peut déménager un petit peu irrégasi
dans cette partie
très clairement
il peut le faire un beau bouger
j'aime beaucoup la position de l'anus
mais
sans doute j'avais aussi pensé à B3 tout
à l'heure
mais évidemment ces trois pour fermer la
pose
et à vrai dire c'est dans cette position
que j'aurais bien aimé faire BK pour le
moment
je voudrais essayer de faire quelque
chose comme ça
et c'est vraiment compliqué d'établir
bienvenue Bienvenue tu me dis bientôt
des nouveaux modules sur Pro Évolution
échec oui exactement ce weekend donc du
coup tu vois la sortie d'impact sur la
CALL du cartor voilà un système blanc un
peu comme le système de Londres mais en
moins connu voilà donc l'ouverture de
cramique quand il y a juste avant de
partir en retraite pour ceux qui
connaissent cramique ils jouent la
catalane et avant de partir en retraite
il a réussi à populariser mon système
fétiche donc j'étais assez content et
surtout voilà pour la petite anecdote
parce que souvent mes collègues de
l'équipe de France ils me disait il me
disait ouais la cause du carter c'est
vraiment
c'est vraiment pour les petits joueurs
et quand cramique a commencé à la jouer
j'étais un peu plus tranquille je
souffre donc voilà pour nous
en fait il y a une petite histoire tu
sais pour pas me prendre la tête avec
les élèves sur la théorie
particulièrement les élèves amateurs
je leur donnais au début le début de
Londres et en fait Magnus en 2013 2014
il a commencé vraiment vraiment à le
jouer intensément et il y a eu une mode
du début de l'ombre quoi si tu veux du
coup
si vous jouez un système et que il est
joué par personne bah c'est hyper
intéressant si les jouets par tout le
monde ça perd un petit peu de son
intérêt même si un système c'est quand
même plus simple et il y a toujours un
intérêt de jouer un système mais c'est
vrai que si vous jouez un système qui en
plus n'est pas connu par les adversaires
bah c'est excellent quoi
et du coup quand Magnus commence à jouer
quelque chose vous pouvez être sûr que
tout le monde va s'y intéresser quoi
voilà et donc je parle de la colle Z la
colle du carter avec le fiancetto un peu
mieux que la colle traditionnelle qui
est une sorte de semis là à l'envers
voilà mais en tout cas la colle c'est un
des bons débuts en fait les systèmes
avec les Blancs pour ceux qui ont pas
envie de se prendre la tête avec les
ouvertures particulièrement les plus
débutants d'entre vous c'est à dire vous
savez bien jouer aux échecs vous
connaissez bien les règles mais vous
démarrez on va dire avec des partis sur
internet avec un peu de compet en club
va commencer par des ouvertures relat
effectivement simple et après dès que
vous avez une meilleure connaissance du
milieu du monde échiquier vous allez
vers des ouvertures plus compliquées
c'est ça donc la colle comme le système
de Londres etc c'est un truc qui sont
assez simples
pour démarrer en tout cas je pense que
des fois je vois il y en a qui sont trop
ambitieux alors dans certains livres
vous verrez les conseils de jouer des
ouvertures riches c'est bien mais avant
d'être riche bah commencer par le
commencement c'est avant de
avant de courir avant de vouloir courir
il faut savoir marcher c'est quelque
chose comme ça qu'on doit dire souffre
je pense c'est à peu près ça
l'expression bah voilà c'est ce que je
pense aux échecs quoi dans la théorie
quoi
je pense que c'est tout à fait ça fait
bien et tu vois tu le tiens un premier
client à quoi lié super
la pause je mettrai le lien à la pause
on fait nos petites pubs à chaque fois
voilà
histoire c'est normalement je propose
toujours des ouvertures qui sont bonnes
dans le temps c'est à dire que on
balance pas la poubelle j'ai un problème
avec le black Mark parce que c'est un de
mes petits coups de cœur mais je sais
que bah je conseille plutôt bah jusqu'à
2000 quoi tu vois sinon après j'estime
que c'est trop dur à jouer il y a trop
de bons systèmes noirs donc je sais ce
que je vais proposer en fait je
proposerai le début jobava voilà pour
ceux qui connaissent la terre au sort
c'est intéressant et d'ailleurs ça a été
beaucoup beaucoup joué même à haut
niveau ça tout le temps hein
qu'il a joué
dans les références une partie entre
Magnus et carwana donc c'est vraiment le
système par excellence pour les gros
bourrins un système crédible pour les
gros bourrins donc les gros bourrins
c'est les joueurs d'attaque d'entre vous
bah ça irait bien un stouf parce que
pour moi dans mon cœur sauf c'est un
gros bourrin désolé c'est tout enfin
c'est pas péjoratif mais c'est les jours
d'attaque quoi
j'aurais bien aimé découvrir ça jusqu'à
mes 18 ans parce que j'avais ce style là
mais après je me suis calmé comme a dit
Néandertal dans le chat je vieillis et
du coup je reste sur
alors oui Robinson mais c'était une
autre époque toi tu es un des dinosaures
du jeu tu le sais bien robinside donc
même si tu la joues à l'accession qu'on
des 23 plus tu as fait 5 et demi sur 6
mais c'était notre époque maintenant je
pense que les gens seraient plus calé
qu'en penses-tu
c'est beaucoup plus dur en théorie de
passer des petits des petits systèmes il
y a des mecs qui arrivent un souffle
mais franchement c'est c'est dur quoi
c'est je me souviens même bon il y a
quelques années déjà Samy il avait joué
le Festival des Jeux à Cannes
contre tout le monde dès qu'il joue un
joueur c'était il attendait sur sa sur
son Blackmar et au final
elle nous avait caché ça et de vous
parler plutôt de heureusement que tu es
la Souf parce qu'il nous paraît que ça
donne anecdote mais ouais je me souviens
il avait joué contre un ennemi français
[Musique]
et il avait joué aussi contre une la
dernière ronde il faisait un tournoi
très moyen pour pas dire même c'est
plutôt mauvais je crois et dernièrement
il a joué une fille il avait une fille à
1900 c'est comme ça et il a dit bon
vas-y je suis en tilte je la joue quand
même on verra ciel connaissait et puis
la fille après elle a sorti 25 août
prépa et ça il était un petit tu vois ça
dernière fois que je le joue
et ça c'est mal passé la fille alors je
sais pas qui c'était d'ailleurs cette
fille c'était pas une Française je pense
et elle a fait une très grosse partie
déjà elle a fait 25 premiers coups comme
un 3000 vélo
parce que bah c'est une préparation
d'ordinateur quoi puis après quand tu as
des camions ben la jupe bien joué quoi
c'est pas fait arnaquer et puis
donc
des 5 E4 un Gambie direct au deuxième
coup
et c'est un petit peu je crois que c'est
toi qui l'a joué
de Belgique c'est assez marrant il a dit
c'était pas Éline Roberts
ça fait pas souvent nul dans le début en
tout cas après c'est une autre chose
et on peut peut-être montrer sauf si ça
te dérange pas on fait une petite
parenthèse sur les petits débuts pour
pour voir
donc là
voilà KFC 3 kf6 fois F4 ce qui est très
intéressant dans ce début là et les D4
sont C4 aux échecs ça peut être ça peut
être très agressif là une des idées
c'est que on a développé deux pièces de
zeldame ce qui est relativement rare et
ça peut permettre de faire le grand rock
c'est pour ça que c'est la grosse baston
dans la ligne F4 pardon qui est assez
représentative avec on balance F3 G4 H4
et on y va on prépare l'attaque avec
f3g4 H4 ça ça envoie et on fait E3 fous
des trois on échange le fou et on fait
grand rock quoi donc et on fait en plus
voilà tout ça E3 fous des trois on
bouffe on bouffe de la dame et du coup
on grand rock et on a les pions qui sont
déjà en G4 h par exemple
ouais ben en fait Robinson toi tu as
joué la vérosoft avec fu G5 à l'ancienne
et du coup maintenant fu F4 est plus
populaire parce que fou G5 et je vois à
l'époque je crois que c'est miles qui
jouait ça
c'est devenu un peu les Noirs égalisent
assez facilement et non pas de problème
alors que ça c'est vraiment le bordel
l'ouverture là c'est bortnik qui joue ça
et je Bava qu'il a joué aussi le grand
maître géorgien assez connu parce que
c'est un joueur assez fantasque il
jouait ce début là ce qui est assez
marrant surtout c'est que le jeu Bava
d'ailleurs il joue des débuts fantasques
avec les Blancs et avec les Noirs il
jouait la carrocane tout le temps tout
le temps
[Musique]
karaoké
c'est de la daube
voilà donc ce qu'il ajoute désolé dans
le chat mais il y a pas de je pense
qu'il y a aucune personne dans le chat
qui joue lait vinsky bon déjà faut que
ça savoir où se trouve que ça s'appelle
comme ça parce que c'est quasiment
impossible moi je l'ai vu sur les
petites notes chasse.com que ça fait à
lidwitzky donc qui joue des 4 D5
fougères 5 normalement personne tu as
déjà vu toi je trouve ce coup-là très
rare
quasiment quoi qu'il arrive
et donc moi je lui ai joué du E6 pour
voir s'il est pris ouvert ou j'ai
toujours et
du coup sur 5
et de quoi j'arrive j'ai réussi à jouer
5 fois c'était pas mal
je sens que c'est pas mal
mais Descartes fougères 5 c'est
c'est juste très mauvais
ok alors
à notre petit truc il se passe plein de
choses on a fait un petit tour des
systèmes
et sur alors juste sauf sur E5 juste on
peut essayer de comprendre ce que Manu
il avait vu sur 5 j'imagine
du coup j'aimerais bien amener mon
cavalier en E4 mais je n'y arrive pas
facilement c'est ça
il peut le croquer peut-être en force tu
peux manger faire un rock
mais peut-être que du coup il lui dit
qu'ils sont pas
c'est très intéressant
c'était dans l'esprit en tout cas de
jouer 5 je pense je pense que Magnus
n'aurait pas joué ça il avait dû prévoir
autre chose
c'est très esthétique comme c'est des
épaulettes c'est un grand match
j'ai vu
mais oui du coup
je vais devoir changer j'ai pas le choix
et du coup il considère peut-être qu'il
a une position solide après après les
dames en fait je pense que juste les
positions là après dame de 4 et comme tu
l'as dit un E5 en rock on l'air vraiment
très très dangereux pour pour le noir vu
qu'ils ont retard de l'Autrement du coup
Carlsen et c'est la finale pour pour pas
enfin pour plus avoir sur le problème tu
vois ça me décide
et là peut-être plutôt quand même rock
plutôt que de manger directement des six
et aller voir un petit peu comment on
joue
il y a beaucoup de temps d'avance quand
même pour pour les blancs
mais
les positions
[Musique]
bon ça reste ça reste extrêmement solide
Magnus j'aime beaucoup son coup d'âme
des 6 puis après on est en train
d'assister à ce qu'on avait dit
potentiellement je trouve c'est pas en
train de s'enflammer
dans la position est en train de se
calmer en fait alors que le reste
d'habitude un gros combattant et là il a
pas vu l'enferment de dames
je pense que d'investis c'est pas un
coup qu'on voit souvent en fait
moi je suis pas fan du Black lion system
en règle générale je dis que c'est très
difficile de jouer des systèmes avec les
noirs avec les Blancs on peut facilement
le faire
avec les Noirs
c'est plus difficile en tout cas j'aime
pas trop quand vous êtes un peu trop
serré et c'est un peu ce qui se passe
toi aux élèves tu leur conseilles quoi
sur quatre
D6 cavalier BD7 toi tu dois pas jouer
des ils font tout le temps des 6 KBC
kf6o5
sauf que toi tu joues tu joues pas le
cavalier en dessin tu crois
pas eux ils jouent avec cavalier BD7 toi
tu
regardes des 6 des 4 toi tu vas faire
cavalier F6 cavalier 3 et je pense tu
vas pas jouer avec moi
aussi en fait
parce que j'ai calme j'ai 5 à h6 et la
H3 et en fait c'est une ligne avec
cavalier 2 foug2 avec un temps d'avance
parce qu'on a fait j'ai 4 ans une fois
quoi
et mais après F4 c'est aussi je crois le
meilleur coup et si on connaît et
théoriquement c'est quand même très bien
pour les blancs
donc c'est une fille d'or si tu veux pas
jouer la finale mais qu'elle est quand
même un coup qui est un peu inférieur
j'ai envie de dire Kevin je pense qu'il
faut accepter de la finale
c'est que enfin toi tu montres ça tes
élèves ou
Deshors généralement enfin c'est dur de
d'expliquer de rien que l'échange des
dames enfin je comprends qu'elle soit
jouée à très haut niveau mais
tu recas toi tu conseilles quoi sauf ça
dépend du niveau de l'élève en fait mais
généralement généralement un élève qui
débute sera plutôt
soit E5 soit
la française que j'aime bien aussi
montrer parce que c'est assez
intéressant niveau schématique niveau
structurelle plus en fait et après quand
tu progresses etc
mais le dragon notamment par exemple
mais par exemple le la fille d'or je
l'ai appris à quelques-uns il y en a
dans le chat d'ailleurs
mais généralement la fluidure c'est pas
une voiture que je monte beaucoup à mes
élèves parce que c'est quand même assez
particulier quand même bien sûr c'est ce
que je trouve aussi et il me dit très
bonne remarque en retard de
développement c'est intéressant
d'échanger les dames oui exactement ce
que ma news vient de faire dans la
position et juste pour pour aller dans
le sens de stouf moi sur 4 globalement
j'ai les Quatre Fantastiques c'est à
dire qu'on peut jouer soit aussi soit C6
donc française 44 et soit 5 soit c'est 5
et E5 et C5 pour aller dans le sens de
ce stuff qui donne pas les mêmes
ouvertures selon le niveau des élèves
pour ma part E5 et C5 c'est pour les
élèves très avancés généralement plus de
parce que E5 donc souffle je sais que tu
le donnes même peut-être à des joueurs
plus faibles c'est très intéressant pour
la richesse du jeu mais je trouve que
les blancs ils ont pas mal d'options et
du coup c'est pour simplifier le travail
que je préfère donner en priorité
française et marocaine pour que ça part
pas dans tous les sens voilà le truc bon
un petit schéma solide
le poulet de Belgique pourquoi les profs
ouais ça c'est les profs français qui
conseillent toujours plus la française
comparé à la carroscan parce qu'on est
Chauvin je pense que c'est ça non mais
les deux sont les deux sont très bien en
fait objectivement
je trouve que la française c'est
légèrement plus facile ou légèrement
en fait selon comment tu la montres mais
voilà légèrement plus facile mais j'aime
beaucoup la carotane aussi sur la
plateforme j'ai fait la carrocane pour
apprendre les échecs j'avais fait la
française
Adila français tu avais fait des vidéos
de YouTube j'avais dû voir les vignettes
ouais j'ai fait une vidéo avec avec les
Noirs bon c'est pas au niveau débutant
j'ai et donc je fais la française je
fais je fais les standing j'ai fait la
carrocane je fais plein de trucs mais
c'est tu vois ces petites lignes sympa
quoi
et voilà je la carreau mais
j'aimais pas du tout tous les positions
que cette année je préfère vraiment
accélérer et là c'est un nouveau monde
c'est naturel
le
une position assez plate
mais
[Musique]
le problème c'est que après une fois que
tu as vraiment progressé à glace Candy à
part Christian Bauer qui est un des
seuls à jouer la scandinave à très haut
niveau Éric priez donc les deux grands
maîtres français que je peux citer sur
le sujet là
c'est quand même chaud pour pour
progresser après quand les adversaires
sont bien préparés en face pareil là le
King je n'aime pas j'ai des élèves qui
ont joué
la lekine par exemple dès que je les
prends en main c'est pas de danakine je
suis très ouvert sur les débuts mais je
veux que ça soit dans les Quatre
Fantastiques C6 C5 E6 E5 donc c'est une
ouverture limitée
des joueurs vous avez des joueurs de
haut niveau qu'ils jouent des des
ouvertures comme jobava etc mais quand
même on voit qu'une majorité de Grand
Maître bah il joue autour des Quatre
Fantastiques donc on va essayer d'aller
dans leur sens en se limitant le travail
parce que les joueurs amateurs vous
pouvez pas ingurgiter la même quantité
de données que les pros et vous avez
aussi moins de temps à consacrer
je propose nul je croyais que tu faisais
que des nuls
mais de toute façon après avec les Noirs
là si on avait une solution miracle à
vous proposer on vous la donnerait avec
sauf mais l'un comme l'autre je pense
qu'on préfère avoir les blancs enfin je
sais pas toi stouffe tu es peut-être
dans ton confort avec baignoire mais moi
j'adore les blancs
donc du coup
c'était facile en plus ouais
c'était facile je vois très très bien
qui tu es
c'était le joueur qui qui jouait en
équipe et qui je pense que ça fait aller
on va deviner ça fait combien de temps
qu'il a pas joué avec les Noirs une
partie d'échec sans sans rien je pense
ça fait cela faire au moins aller 15 ans
qu'il a pas de une seule partie avec les
noirs
je crois
et il est blanc et c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que il faisait beaucoup de nuls et
il faisait beaucoup de nuls et en fait
soit il gagnant en moins d'un coup soit
il faisait nul 15 20 ans qui n'a pas
joué
je serais content de jouer avec lui en
équipe du coup moi j'avais moi j'avais
un pote à l'époque quand j'étais au club
de Nice qui joue il est il voulait tout
le temps avoir les Noirs tout le temps
donc moi j'étais content j'ai dit bah ok
écoute et du coup on peut tourner tous
les deux donc du coup moi je prenais
souvent les blancs ils prenaient
beaucoup les noirs
qui avait été exceptionnel en top de
faire une norme de gemmes si je dis pas
de bêtises en prenant que les Noirs
j'avais fait une énorme de Mimi en
prenant en fait c'était une saison il y
avait on avait 11 parties en N1 et du
coup j'avais commencé avec avec 8 fois
les noirs
et j'avais bon j'avais un super score
non cette fois les noirs et après du
coup j'avais un harnais week-end enfin
la norme sur 9 parties et du coup il
fallait que je fasse un demi sur deux je
vais calculer et je devais jouer un
grand maître français alors je sais plus
comment il s'appelle Bricard
et un 2200 et j'avais prévu de de
du coup de enfin il fallait que je fasse
un point et demi quoi donc c'est bon je
vais prendre les blancs contre Ricard
quand même plus dur mais c'est de faire
nul et puis le lendemain c'est mes
cheveux nul et ben je joue avec les
Noirs contre un enfin je vois que les
blancs du coup je voulais doubler blanc
contre 2002 enfin maintenant et du coup
moi j'ai pris des blancs et du coup donc
le objectif faire nul contre Emmanuel
Ricard qui crame qui avait 2500 Hello
et donc j'ai eu j'ai pris les blancs et
j'ai gagné la partie j'ai gagné en voilà
à peu près 18 coups il m'a donné une
pièce mais genre une combinaison mais de
facile quoi il a il a oublié un détail
quoi et du coup ben j'ai gagné la pièce
là avant d'aller direct du coup bah le
lendemain il fallait que je fasse nul
ben j'ai repris les Noirs
j'aurais pu prendre les blancs j'avais
dit que je double relais blanc mais en
fait au final l'équipe jouait pour le
maintien donc c'est important que que
faire je voulais pas prendre les blancs
et Fanny
donc j'ai pris les noirs et j'ai fait
une en fait j'ai fait une arme de mi
avec 8 fois les noirs sur neuf au final
moi j'ai fini la dernière en plus
c'était une ouverture le mec qui me joue
une il me joue une une Anglaise et je
propose nulle rapidement au cinquième
coup un petit comme ça et bon ça partait
du matin
j'ai fait une super saison lui pas trop
je lui manquer on fait nul quoi et il me
dit bah non on va jouer un peu quand
même tu vois ça fait cinq coups quand
même
et du coup là j'ai arrêté d'avoir pris
des blancs quoi et du coup ben j'ai
quand même fait nul mais on a joué on a
joué 4h 5h
puis à la fin je peux je pour gagner
mais enfin tu sais j'ai la
finale typique avec Dame cavaler contre
dame fou ou je peux mettre un peu la
pression mais bon ça doit être ça doit
être nul hein
pour une norme de maître j'ai même pas
essayé c'était ma première en plus
c'est toujours un peu plus facile de
faire des normes on peut aller vous
faire jouer
ma dernière norme de Grand Maître stouf
j'avais zéro sur deux à faire
ça c'était bon mais il fallait que
j'aille taper une moyenne élo hyper
forte à 2700
et jouer au bas David Navara genre Meyer
et j'ai fait facilement mes 0 sur 2 et
voilà tranquille voilà une belle façon
de faire
mieux mais les mecs ils font pas trop
cadeau moi j'avais aussi j'avais aussi
le même cas que toi c'est comme toi que
j'ai fait deux ans moins un an il y
avait il y avait une année où vous avez
7 sur 7 j'avais 7 sur 7 et j'avais joué
un seul titré un mètre etc et j'avais
des maîtres etc mais j'avais un seul
petit trait et
du coup deux dernières secondes je sais
plus compte qui ont joué mais il me
fallait absolument un mètre un grand
maître
et du coup je savais que je pouvais
faire zéro en fait voilà et il me
fallait absolument avoir maître et grand
maître et du coup quand je suis arrivé
premier jour je me suis mis le plus haut
possible et j'en ai eu un et le
lendemain bah je prie encore maître
quand je fais zéro sur deux mais
voilà là même technique je trouve que il
se moque un peu de toi qui dit mais
utile se trouve de faire une norme quand
on en a cinq normes
figure-toi que ça même si tu as plein de
normes et que tu as faim encore une et
bah ça va toujours plaisir quand même de
faire un homme ça montre que que tu es
encore là que c'est pas encore fini qui
est encore espoir tu vois bah c'est
quand tu fais tes normes depuis trop
longtemps et que finalement tu arrives
pas à passer 2400 hello en plus moi je
l'ai descendu j'avais eu un été j'ai
fait un été horrible quand j'avais 4
normes de mètres j'avais 23,90 et que
j'ai perdu 110 points en trois tournois
j'ai envie de mourir
j'étais à 22,80
je suis parti pendant des mois et au
final ben j'avais un pote là-bas sur
place qui qui gérait un club d'échec et
me dit bah si tu veux il y a la Ligue là
tu peux jouer en plus je compte des
Forgeur contre des maîtres etc moi j'ai
dit non non et pendant en fait il y
avait tous les week-ends samedi et
dimanche et pendant peut-être trois mois
j'ai refusé refusé j'avais pas j'ai une
seule partie je voulais pas j'en ai
marre quoi
et au final ben la dernière ronde du
championnat il a assisté il m'a dit
apparemment en faisant une quoi au moins
tu partiras
par expérience mais je résume une partie
tu vois c'est vrai que c'est cool et
donc je suis à l'aise un mètre
et après je dis bon vas-y c'est super
les échecs du coup bah ouais c'est pas
si mauvais mais bon j'ai gagné quoi j'ai
gagné 10 points quoi j'étais encore
encore moins de 2003 et au final après
je suis parti Martel aux Canaries et
j'ai fait deux tournois et j'ai fait
cinq amis sur 6 en équipe au premier
checker contre
2300 et donc j'ai gagné 40 points une
quarantaine d'elos et après j'ai fait
une lampe de maître juste derrière donc
je suis remonté à 2380 en fait en deux
temps mois mais
au final ça fait plaisir tu dis bon ok
il y a il y a 2 ans j'avais 2003 j'avais
2280 tu as tu vois que la descente que
tu as fait aux enfers ben peut-être que
c'était une erreur en fait tu te rends
vachement question quoi
c'est souvent moi quand j'aimais pierre
hello ça m'a en fait démot dans un
premier temps mais dans un second temps
ça m’a mis un bon coup de boost aussi
donc je vois bien parce que
il en faut trois pour être maître
trois points de crevettes comme toi mais
en avoir plus ça sert absolument à rien
par contre je t'ai bien écouté stouf tu
m'as dit que ça faisait plaisir de faire
de nouvelles normes moi ma dernière
norme de grand-mère c'était en 2012 et
depuis c'est un peu le calme plat mais
toujours
au top pourraient potentiellement faire
un tournoi deux parents mais tu fais de
ton apparence en fait
c'est dur tu vois mettre c'est hyper dur
quoi et j'ai d'ailleurs pas à renoncé
depuis
ce fameux zéro sur deux j'ai pas menacé
dans d'en faire d'ailleurs j'ai quand
même j'ai fait une saison
ou un an où j'avais une performance
hello à quasiment 2600 vélo
je suis allé à on a fait la compo etc et
ben j'ai joué le seul joueur donc il
trait et du coup il manquait j'avais
tout j'avais tout j'avais trois et demi
j'avais un seul maître de fille j'avais
tout ça fait une perte de 2006 j'avais 8
j'avais 7 ans 8 et le pire c'est que la
partie je l'ai gagné quoi il y a
beaucoup de joueurs comme ça qui est
court c'est Pierre Belley qui récemment
est passé grand maître
et il a beaucoup galéré alors que de
très peu il aurait pu vraiment faire
faire des normes et il avait pas la
réussite alors que en terme de Hello il
était montré enfin vraiment haut tu vois
genre 25-40 ou pas loin
et il rater je sais pas mais plus de 5
occasions un demi point après quoi tu
vois il y a des mecs qui commencent à
poisser un peu et après c'est dur
psychologiquement quoi
bien sûr enfin c'était tout à fait
légitime mais malheureusement bah tant
que tu as pas le titre tu es coincé quoi
alors ben ce bon vieux Magnus il va il
va jouer contre Jordan je pense qu'il a
déjà égalisé hein je pense qu'il a gagné
aussi parce que le foot est très fort en
V5 d'ailleurs je me suis posé la
question si d'un point c'était vraiment
bien parce qu'en fait au final le fond
qu'il est plutôt fort
je pense que Jordan van forest c'est pas
à l'aise avec la position et si tu veux
bah il a pas mal réfléchi il a pas
trouvé mais il a joué un coup maintenant
non compromettant parce que le problème
c'est que sur ça on te reprend la tête
du fousset 5 je prends le 3 mais surtout
c'était pas le problème juste
ben je sais pas ça avait l'air
cavalier
5 et essayer de revenir ou alors je joue
un peu pénible
en tout cas pas trop de
trucs
[Musique]
toutes les règles merci à toi tu as fait
notre travail merci beaucoup à tout
expliquer pour ceux qui veulent avoir
les infos
et une fois que vous avez bien lu ce que
nous a mis épimélial il vous reste plus
qu'à faire les perfs voilà il vous reste
plus qu'à respecter ce qui est indiqué
la pire anecdote notre pierre loose
notre pierre loose c'est un peu ça je
pense
non bah c'était une partie que j'avais
joué à la ronde un tournoi dans Le Pen
dans le Sud-Ouest
et j'avais joué en fait
je jouais pour une norme enfin non
j'avais on va dire le niveau pour
commencer un peu à faire à essayer de
faire des normes tu vois donc on
rappelle la norme pour stouf la norme de
Metz c'est 2450
de performance sur un tournoi avec le
fait d'avoir rencontré aussi un certain
nombre de titres en général 5 donc sur
une sur 9 rondes 5 3 m 3 mètres
internationaux et 2 mètres filtre si je
n'ai pas de bêtise c'est grossièrement
ça
et la norme de grand-mère c'est pareil
sauf qu'il faut jouer des grands maîtres
et des maîtres et il faut que vous ayez
à la fin une performance à 2600 sur
l'ensemble du tournoi voilà grosso modo
pour schématiser c'est ça et du coup je
le tournoi et j'avais bon c'était la
ronde un donc bon faut pas faire une
normale mais juste l'idée si tu veux de
faire un bon temps moi quoi et de
pouvoir jouer pour la main c'est cool
et du coup alors on a joué en 1800
qui
en fait ne va jamais venir au tournoi
d'accord il a existé il avait oublié de
s'inscrire du coup
bon je vais gagner parfois donc bon je
suis un peu blasé parce que bah je suis
venu c'est le tournoi est loin etc je
gagne pas forcer la première rencontre
voilà et en plus je gagne parfois en
fait tu sais que les normes de de mettre
à son quasiment en fait
parce qu'il faut que je neuf partis et
que gains forfait ça compte pas quoi et
tu peux faire 8 parties si t'as pas
besoin de faire un point sur la 9e en
fait en gros si comme toi tu avais tu
peux faire zéro sur deux là dans la
parole dans la partie tu vois c'est le
score qu'il faut ta jolie très etc tu
peux faire une arme sur 8
bon en gros moi je vois que je vais
faire ça donc je vais voir l'ordinateur
et je
dis rien mais juste on parle et c'est
dommage quoi et il me dit tiens j'ai une
idée il y a un jour exemple
si tu veux comme ça moi ça fait une
partie quoi donc bah écoute cool je suis
content donc moi j'avais
2280 trucs comme ça en vélo
et il me fait rire contre un joueur à
1400 € exemple c'était le dernier le
tournoi donc moi je suis content je dis
bah écoute peu importe l'écoute
l'adversaire de toute façon c'est un
genre qui a un tout remonté à 2050 du
coup en fait
par rapport à la moyenne d'Elo le plus
faible sera remonté à 2050 ça commence
c'est les règles donc du coup qui fait
1400 1800 pour moi cet appareil quoi
bien sûr donc je suis content en plus là
c'est sûr que je vais gagner vu que j'ai
quand même 800 hello d'avance puisque
lui je gagne quoi
donc du coup ben voilà on commence à
partir etc et puis j'ai joué la partie
de manière très
peut pas dire marginale mais en fait je
l'avais pris de haut voilà ça parce que
ben il y a eu plein d'événements qui
sont pas etc qui fait une partie
absolument dégueulasse je me souviens
pour te dire un peu moins attitude
pendant la partie Kevin c'était une
Sicilienne fermée
donc je sais plus exactement comment ça
s'est joué d'accord
mais dans l'idée en fait
imaginé un truc du style
moi j'avais joué avec mon cavalier en 7
je crois tu vois un truc du style comme
ça donc je sais plus comment c'était
et en fait dans cette position là
je pense que cette exposition là et ben
il m'a joué ici il faut H6 qui est bon
normal quoi
et moi dans ma tête je me suis dit bon
ok il va changer les fous bon le coup
normal c'est petit rock et après il y a
même plein de lignes avec du H4
voilà c'est assez connu etc mais bon moi
je me suis dit mais en fait je vais
mater vite quoi donc du coup vu que je
le mate rapidement
et je vais jouer à chaque fois
en me disant
bah une fois qu'il prend je prends et je
fais H5 et je pousse et je matais quoi
avec ma tour
le problème c'est que bon là il peut
juste faire [ __ ] et puis je suis
content
mais le pire c'est sur ça il a il a pas
mangé il a joué un truc de style je sais
plus mon cabalio 2 un truc comme ça et
là je dis bon t'inquiète t'inquiète
tracasse comme dirait nos amis les
Belges
et ben j'ai dit bah je suis calé j'ai 8
comme ça au moins bah s'il prend bah je
prends et je fais H5 quoi
et du coup donc on va voir ça il a mangé
et qui est pas bon d'ailleurs
juste fou 3 et là j'ai vraiment l'air
d'un
conte voilà un jour il y a un moment
donné il a pris le cavalier pour faire
un truc et puis en gros je me suis pris
un petit échec d'un procès 5 voilà et
j'ai perdu deux pions j'avais deux pions
de moi en bout de 15 coups et
complètement foutu contre 1400 ça fait
tout ce que j'ai pu pour remonter
remonter remonter remonter j'arrive à
récupérer tous les pions mais tellement
foutu que franchement il a fait une
bonne partie et il m'a battu
et vraiment perdu quand on mille quatre
quoi donc j'ai perdu la partie contre
1400 et en plus quand tu vois quand tu
vois voilà l'arbitre ouais bah je joue
quand même pour une norme de maître
et tu perds ton 1400 alors tu es allé
voir la [ __ ] pour avoir un adversaire
j'avais un peu la honte et
et en plus bon je joue un petit jeune un
petit jeune Toulousain
et
bon c'est un enfant moi j'avais presque
à 21 ans un truc comme ça et à la fin de
la partie donc moi j'avais laissé la
feuille sur la table enfin tu vois je
voulais même pas récupérer et le gamin
il vient me voir il me dit monsieur vous
avez oublié votre feuille dessus
et voilà je crois que c'était ma pire
pire mon pire souvenir et je sais qu'il
y a un terme de qui est compatible voilà
c'est arrivé à d'autres
[Musique]
ouais en 2008 2009
non peut-être pas peut-être plus moi je
sais plus mais par là
non ce jeune il a et le pire c'est que
la la partie d'après ce jeune il a fait
nul train et demi
à 2000 quasiment 2400
le MI qui avait une position
gagnante en fait
et du coup comme le gamin il m'a évacu
la veille le MI il a un petit côté en
disant que le gamin était hyper fort
alors que pas du tout juste une bonne
partie que moi j'avais fait n'importe
quoi et du coup le MI au lieu de mater
et ben il avait un perpète il a pris le
perpète contre le 1400 et le 1400 du
coup il avait un et demi sur deux contre
un 2400 et moi qui a quasiment 2003
et les gens commencent à parler il est
hyper fort il va faire une norme de
mètres etc bon le gamin il a fini 309
quoi
peut-être qu'il jouait 1500 quoi donc
voilà gros ça c'était c'était mon
anecdote j'espère que la tienne elle a
aussi bonne que la mienne
franchement j'ai une journée il me
semble que c'était 2009 tu vois donc bon
j'étais 24-50 toujours pareil
et là je joue un 23 polonais bon au bout
de je sais pas au bout de 12 coups il
est foutu aucun au bout de 15 coups il a
une pièce de moi quoi j'ai deux j'ai
deux enfin il a deux pions mais il est
complètement foutu quoi donc j'attends
quand il abandonne sauf que le joueur
polonais et d'ailleurs j'ai des jouets
des tournants en Pologne les mecs bah
ils s'accroche quel que soit la position
quoi bon je joue un peu à la main de
toute façon ça a bien finir par gagner
cette histoire
et puis moi je comprends que je suis en
train de faire de la merde et du coup
que ça commence à se rapprocher de la
nul quoi tu vois
mais bon je suis quand même complètement
gagnant puis bon ma technique fait le
reste et du coup au lieu de gagner en 15
coups et voilà enfin c'était vraiment si
je m'étais appliqué au bon moment
c'était bon je me suis pas appliqué ça
merde complet OK et du coup je fais nul
en 6 heures sauf mais là c'est pas fini
l'anecdote
c'est que c'est double ronde donc ça
c'était la ronde du matin
donc après il me reste à aller jouer un
22/50
et du coup cette fois j'ai plus les
blancs comme le matin où j'avais obtenu
un avantage des CIF dans l'ouverture
j'ai les noirs
contre un mec bon je vois je vois direct
ce qui va se passer il me joue une
ouverture très solide si le catalan
c'était une ouest je crois et du coup il
essaie de me bétonner la tronche pour
faire nul quoi
et du coup il y arrive quoi c'est
quasiment nul mais ça y est au bout de 5
heures de jeu donc ça fait 6h le matin
5h donc c'est la 11e heure de jeu de la
journée
ça y est le mec crac il me laisse
déséquilibrer la position et on joue
tout fout trois contours cavalier 3
sauf que ces trois pions pas de la même
aile donc on a trois pions passés chacun
quoi
et je me rappelle il y avait des
collègues maîtres et un grand maître et
il me disent à la fin de la partie avec
Kevin nous aussi on a cru que tu allais
gagner
du coup bah j'avais tout le temps de me
tofu quoi donc on a l'impression que
c'est bien pour moi mais en fait c'est
trois pions sont arrivés sur la tronche
je pouvais rien faire et visuellement ça
avait l'air d'être mieux pour moi et en
fait c'était nul si je jouais bien quoi
donc j'ai perdu donc j'ai fait un demi
sur deux je pense que j'ai joué 11h30
12h dans la journée pour faire un demi
sur deux contre une moyenne 200 points
et l'eau en dessous de moi un mec qui
était complètement foutu au bout de 15
coups et un mec qui avait joué pour la
nul à fond toute la partie mais cette
cette journée je pense que je m'en
souviendrai toute ma vie quoi tire
journée chicane quoi toi tu sors de là à
part boire une bille je t'as pas tu as
pas beaucoup de solutions je peux te
dire je pense que juste des fois et
quand je dis une je suis léger hein
mais je pense que juste que juste des
fois quand il y a des jours où c'est
juste c'est juste horrible quoi
[Musique]
qui nous parlait de ça quoi du groupe
une fois j'ai eu du mal avec un cavalier
en équipe
mais du coup ouais bah Ahmed tu as bien
répondu et professionnel aussi il
connaît dans ce cas là si
la vie est dure le Breton sait comment
sait comment réagir dans ces cas-là mais
ouais là c'est extrêmement dur les
échecs je peux vous dire quand vous
quand vous perdez une partie au bout de
6 heures bon là c'est là c'est comme
deux défaite quoi mais c'est encore plus
dur mais une partie au bout de 6 heures
il y a les expressions en vous parlez
aux oiseaux vous parlez tout seul mais
en tout cas on voit ce que ça veut dire
c'est que c'est même pas content que
vous êtes c'est complètement démoralisé
et vous pensez à autre chose quoi
en tout cas moi je tiens je tiens à dire
qu'après ma partie que j'ai perdu contre
1400 j'étais très très content quelques
mois quelques mois derrière de pouvoir
de pouvoir rencontrer pour la première
fois Kevin thérieux lors du tournoi en
2009 à Calvi et
je vais être obligé de faire une vidéo
de la partie que j'ai perdu quoi avant
contre monolone et du coup la conclusion
c'est après je pouvais perdre contre
tout le monde même qu'on souffre un truc
comme ça
en plus de n'importe quoi parce que
quand on a joué ensemble j'avais que
2005 donc en fait ma partie contre le
mystère non mais c'était bien plus tard
en fait
ça devait être deux trois ans après toi
c'est incroyable quoi incroyable 1400
ouais là c'est normalement tu as une
petite marge sauf 1400 c'est c'est quand
même en partie lente
pour vous donner une idée ouais c'est le
niveau
c'est le niveau qu'on avait je sais pas
8 ans quoi donc du coup c'est comme si
on jouait ce qu'on soit même à 8 ans et
du coup
mais oui non j'ai commencé tôt
d'ailleurs les lônes valaient plus rien
dire si tu veux tout parce que
en poussant par exemple donc c'est un
poussin donc c'était 9 ans peut-être
j'avais 1400 1450 c'était moelleux
c'était troisième et l'autre France et
genre le numéro 1 c'était 15 10 tu vois
et
ça a vraiment fortement évolué en
pupille dans ma catégorie quand j'étais
en première année c'était Sébastien
Mazet je me rappelle il avait un lot qui
faisait peur c'était 1990 et je trouvais
déjà fou alors qu'aujourd'hui on voit
beaucoup de jeunes qui ont déjà des très
très bons élo
très très jeune quoi voilà quelle époque
tu avais le classement le classement FFE
qui oui bien sûr qui sort
à chaque classe moins FFE tous les six
mois on est content on allait voir
combien j'ai des lots combien j'ai de
l'eau alors que maintenant avec Luffy tu
peux le calculer toi-même enfin c'est à
l'époque c'était vraiment la surprise tu
savais que que au 1er juillet c'était
alors j'ai quand même des lots tu vois
et tu étais enfin c'était pour moi
c'était un truc hyper important
[Musique]
de site web ils ont ils ont pas trop à
voir avec les Lola bon déjà c'est pas la
même cadence mais en plus les sites web
en général les interfaces sont sont
généreuses en termes de vélo
quand même très clairement et chaise.com
encore c'est pas la plus généreuse il y
a je dirais que il y a il y a des
plateformes qui sont encore plus
généreuses donc faut faire très très
attention souvent il y en a qui me
disent ouais j'ai un gros hello sur
chescom mais quand il démarre la vraie
vie du joueur d'échec en compet en
partie lente elle s'aperçoivent que
c'est vraiment dur de gagner des points
parce qu'en plus quand on joue plein de
je sais pas de partie Blitz sur tchat
score on en fait beaucoup
alors que pour gagner les points hello
en long c'est très long voilà
je pense que c'est plus de 200 points
souffrant à peu près par exemple je suis
24 50 en blitz dans la vraie vie ce qui
doit être mon niveau 24 60 et
surchauffe.com je peux 26 50 donc il y a
200 points
je pense même pas qui est 200 points en
fait je pense ça dépend ça dépend de de
beaucoup de monde en fait parce que il y
a des joueurs qui sont plus ou moins
fort que d'autres sur internet ou en
blitz ou rapide pour moi ça n'a rien à
voir il y a des joueurs qui sont qui
sont moi j'ai j'ai un ami qui a 2200 et
quelques kilos en même temps quasiment
2003 en vrai et il a quasiment le même
élo sur Internet
du coup je vais voir si je peux le virer
est-ce que ça va mieux du coup je vais
virer
des micro de caméras
qui a fait une petite pirouette
technique vous permettant de mieux
sentir la salle de jeux voilà
mais non c'est pas c'est pas joie je
parle pas de lui mais il y a des joueurs
qui ont qui ont un vélo oui avec son pas
forcément bon sur Internet etc comparé à
d'autres qui sont un peu moins fort mais
qui ont des gros gros gros zéro sur
internet donc
tu vois moi par exemple par rapport à
mon pote qui a eu 2300 il y a pas très
longtemps bon on avait quasiment le même
vélo quoi alors sur Internet j'avais 300
points faciles puisque lui quoi
sur internet quand
je prends la moyenne je vois les
exemples que j'ai quand même autour de
moi c'est mais après c'est ça commence
si vous voulez être un petit peu
représentative voilà mais c'est pas
parce que j'ai 1500 et lots que c'est
moins de 100 voilà ça par contre c'est
mais ça peut vous donner un petit peu
genre d'idée quoi
mais ça veut ça veut rien dire quoi
oui ça reste en arabe 2400 mais ça veut
pas dire que 1400 ans parce que si
c'était le cas je pense que je serais
Mika
j'aurais réussi à passer 2400 là quoi
mais maintenant
et oui il y en a qui sont style Michel
sur les chaises c'est largement pire là
vraiment j'ai des élèves qui ont des
lots considérables ils sont contents
mais en fait le vrai hello pour moi
c'est c'est le lent celui de compet bien
sûr et c'est ça qui fait la force d'un
joueur enfin vraiment c'est le hello
qu'on connaît le mieux même les lots
aujourd'hui Blitz en réel sont pas
encore calibrés parce que ça fait trop
peu longtemps que ça existe
précieusement c'est ma technique aussi
on a la même voilà
après c'est clair qu'il y a entre les
pièces et com ben je pense qu'il y a au
niveau plutôt débutant plutôt vers le
bas et ben les pièces c'est plus
généreux mais après ça se rééquilibre
plus vers le haut quoi c'est à dire que
moi j'avais à peu près les mêmes élo en
fait sur le site
moi je vais me préparer
je pense à un îlot plus fort mais après
un élo un vélo plus bas c'est plus
généreux souvent un joueur qui a
peut-être
1500 sur chetcom il va avoir peut-être
plutôt 1800 sur les chaises quoi par
exemple je pense
mais après plus tu plus tu as des lots
plus ça c'est équilibre en fait
donc
j'avais plus de sang de chasse comme
plus 300 litchi et après ben bien sûr on
peut on peut ajuster
sauf ce qui disait sur le le jeu sur
Internet ou tout ça c'est vrai que c'est
une autre façon de voir les choses et
c'est intéressant aussi c'est assez dur
de vous répondre avec ultra précision
en tout cas
pour un bon nombre de joueurs je pense
que c'est quand même plus généreux sur
internet
pour installer
[Rires]
la discussion on vient juste de terminer
dehors la réponse est non mais si tu
veux écouter la réponse je conseille de
repartir un tout petit peu en arrière et
got je crois que c'était contre toi
c'est sûr que c'était contre contre
souffre parce que j'ai jamais été à
Luchon
[Rires]
parce que c'est du son
[Musique]
dans le chat et qu'on l'a pris pour nous
quoi tu vois ouais ouais
bon les Pyrénées
à Luchon il y a pas des bouteilles d'eau
il y a pas de des sources non source de
Luchon je crois qu'il y a un truc
on se fait un peu suer dans cette
position est-ce que ça va s'équilibrer
rapidement
une découverte sur la dame on
probablement cavaler prendre des cartes
et celui qui a les points F3 on peut
espérer éventuellement récupérer le pion
A6 mais il y a pas de gagner directement
est-ce que vous me conseillez d'aller en
tournant rapide parce que je joue sur
sur Internet oui joue en IRL très
clairement c'est beaucoup mieux
enfin c'est beaucoup mieux c'est
différent mais si tu veux si tu es
passionné d'échec va sentir un peu les
pièces va palper de la pièce ok c'est
pas envie de jouer en long parce que je
comprends tu as commencé plus tard les
échecs et du coup ça te ça te saoulera
un petit peu mais va te faire plaisir en
rapide au printemps il y a beaucoup de
tournois dans tous les régions de France
et c'est vraiment très sympathique et
vraiment peu engageant parce que c'est
des tournois
sur une journée donc ça peut être une
bonne transition et après pourquoi pas
aller vers le long si jamais tu sens que
tout va bien quoi
on n'a pas de français sur le tournoi on
a Magnus
qui est en difficulté donc le numéro 1
mondial
on a dix reines numéro 2 mondial qui a
une moyenne
mais on n'a pas nos Français à l'IRESA
firuggia et et Maxime va chez Lagrave
voilà on a expliqué un petit peu les
raisons tout au long bah déjà faut avoir
une invitation sous Fadi plusieurs fois
qu'elle resa il avait eu un souci avec
l'organisation il y a deux ans
Maxime va chez Lagrave n'a pas été
invité et puis il avait pas trop envie
de le faire en plus il est dans une
période un petit peu de transition voilà
donc
[Musique]
voilà ce qu'on peut vous dire sur ce
sujet là
donc là il y a une
proposition nulle de la part de gamer
j'ai l'impression
il y a pas répété encore tu vois il
vient de jouer ici foot et 5
et merci pour le message pour dame
et il peut y avoir une proposition mais
bon du coup je pense que c'est pas la
jouer en tout cas je vous rappelle que
les gens n'ont pas de faire nul avant 30
coups et trois heures de jeu donc on va
pas sauf à annuler avec les blancs comme
ça rapide
alors Sophia elkachi qui me demande
quand je fais le tata style ben pas de
sitôt je pense et il me semble que donc
à l'époque ça s'appelle chorus je dis
pas de bêtises
en tout cas il y avait trois tournois il
me semble open a baissé soufre si je dis
pas de bêtises hein oui il y a le bon il
y a le tournoi master quand on regarde
ici il y a le challenger qui se qualifie
pour le Master et il y a un autre
tournoi après à côté derrière qui
recrute la semaine donc
voilà il me semble qu'il y avait un
tournoi assez si tu veux pour avec le
même schéma je parle d'intro à fermer
c'est peut-être j'ai une bêtise mais il
me semblait je sais pas
et si un tournoi assez en tout cas
vous pourrez tout juste quoi
et oui on a on a déjà fait les
championnats de France avec stouf on va
voir après je sais pas si on parle de
du comment dirais-je
tu championnat de catégorie ou de
championnats de jeunes pour ma part j'ai
fait jeunes championnat de France même
championnat du monde deux fois en moins
de 18 et moins de 20 ans avec je l'ai
expliqué Mathieu cornade qui est passé
avec stouf dans les stream c'était le
numéro un de ma catégorie donc deux fois
je suis à cheval du monde avec Mathieu
c'était d'ailleurs des bons moments
parce qu'en moins de 18 et moins de 20
ans quand vous faites
ces tournois là déjà vous passez des
supers moments c'est hyper convivial et
vous jouez les plus forts joueurs de la
planète de votre catégorie d'âge donc
pour ma part c'était ma médias le
meilleur joueur mais il y en avait
beaucoup de la génération c'est les
tournois exceptionnels qu'on a la chance
de faire ça c'est top ici il Magnus
avait fait une norme EN tournoi C je
crois c'est possible Chloé salut à toi
Chloé
que je reconnais au pseudo voilà
pseudo très masqué mais au moins on
reconnaît les gens quoi ils ont des
pseudos comme ça on a des petites idées
et merci en tout cas pour
pour l'info
moi les épices j'ai joué le nasal B en
fait à moins de 900 B qui regroupé les
les
deux fois 10 joueurs ou deux fois de 12
joueurs moi je vois dans le deuxième
tournoi j'ai fait l'accession aussi
trois fois j'ai fait plusieurs fois
l'accession une fois j'ai terminé
premier execo ce qui m'avait qualifié
dans le dans le National B à l'époque et
plus enfin il y avait ce truc là qui a
disparu maintenant voilà
et l'accession aussi c'est un beau
tournoi
parce que c'est un beau tournoi à faire
la baston la baston avec des joueurs
français j'ai fait une fois l'opena
moins de 2002 c'était en 2008
à Pau
je suis allé
et
puis voilà après je m'intéressais par je
pars sur le championnat parce que moi
j'aime bien partir
à l'étranger pour jouer aux échecs
exactement comme toi mais il y avait la
calife au bout tu sais on a vu
alors on a quand même l'exemple de mes
collègues bretons Jean-François Joly qui
est maître plutôt entre 23,50 et 24 qui
s'est qualifié à l'accession pour le
national a et après il a failli gagner
le cheval de France c'était quand même
hallucinant il a fini 3e du National a
alors qui partait dernier sur la sur la
ligne de départ et en plus que dans ce
tournoi là avec Bacro et compagnie il y
a jamais trop de surprises quand vous
êtes entre guillemets le client du
tournoi c'est à dire le moins bon et
l'eau vous faites bien fidéliser et lui
avait fait l'exploit terminé troisième
et sur la dernière partie il aurait pu
battre Sébastien Mazet et être champion
de France et il pas si loin sur la
partie
l'année suivante tout est rentré dans
l'ordre puisqu'il s'est requalifié pour
la salle et par contre cette fois ci ça
a été beaucoup plus dur pour
Jean-François qui a fini avant dernier
me semble-t-il mais en tout cas il y a
cet exemple là quand même qui qui donne
envie qui donne envie en fait qui est
mais juste avec ses nombreux point qu'il
avait fait il était qualifié d'office
et quand tu arrives 3e tu fais pas les
califes quoi oui exactement
et du coup après voilà mais non il a
fait un support comment je m'en souviens
c'était hallucinant c'était hallucinant
toujours bouder des gros tournois suite
au conflit en Ukraine ou pas vraiment je
pense pas que c'est un joueur qui va sur
beaucoup invité encore
là là c'est plus aussi qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de place stoufonnement mais je
pense même que c'est un joueur en fait
j'ai vu qu'il y a beaucoup de joueurs
qui fait mal à la porte
donc
oui oui et en plus bon bah il joue plus
trop d'échecs
[Musique]
parlons de terminer
c'est pour pas dire terminer
pour voir un peu et là on voit quand
même que il a joué dame F5 coûte très
ambitieux sauf on va passer la dame
il a pas répété il va venir là
on y va on peut faire quoi
pour l'instant d'ambiance
pendant qu'on fait ce petit tour
alors du coup du coup car c'est votre
forest donc à Hassan qui
qui s'ouvre là qui joue une petite
position sans risque assez
et du coup je pense dans cette position
un peu ça risque ben je pense qu'il va
qui va prendre l'avantage au fur et à
mesure et moi je veux une victoire car
ici
il est quand même c'est quand même un
super joueur
pour moi il y a pas encore davantage
noir mais c'est vrai que les
perspectives ont l'air plus réjouissante
côté noir on a le roi centralisé un peu
plus d'espace maintenant sur les ailes
on a commencé à envoyer les pions
maintenant pour gagner ça justement ça
pourrait être une belle masterclass de
Magnus aujourd'hui en tout cas
j'aimerais bien parce que si je jouais
un joueur plus faible comme moi dans
cette position mais légèrement je me
dirais ça va être dur à gagner donc
Magnus là c'est
lui mais
il a aucune chance de perdre et puis
généralement les finales quand même dans
le Celian sont son meilleur pour les
noirs de manière générale parce que j'ai
une colonne c'est une structure qui est
très solide et là par exemple quand on
regarde les pièces on voit que le café
dans ces trois il a pas beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à faire là les fous
un jour se changeront et de fou en E2
c'est une pièce qui est assez mauvaise
dans la structure dans ce pion donc moi
je vois quand même plus de possibilités
pour les Noirs même si bon bah
ça reste quand même assez légal et qui
encore une partie à jouer
donc car c'est niveau se refaire
quelque chose
je le vois mettre la pression en tout
cas
ok
7 donc qui veut absolument échanger des
fous je pense que c'est
la bonne décision c'est vous qui peut
vraiment être très fort si jamais
j'arrivais à menacer des maths etc et
maintenant bah je pense que sauve pas
pouvoir faire autre chose que changer
parce que reculer le fou ce serait
graphique donc
les fous vont se changer et puis après
il y a encore une partie c'est pas dire
que c'est clair mais
peut-être imaginer un petit peu prendre
set avec un petit tour des hanches qui a
l'air pas mal
perso
je sais pas comment tu défends ton je
crois que c'est impossible si tu bouges
le pion ben je vais te manger en fait en
passant ou juste manger comme ça et du
coup le pur est la canne perdu là du
coup ça comme des menaces concrètes les
pièces noires qui jouent pas
je sais pas comment on joue
ouais
[Musique]
un peu de mal à comprendre comment les
Noirs vont se défendre
j'ai quand même beaucoup de trucs à
gérer
peut-être jusqu'à
là j'ai pas trouvé après comme on allait
bouger après genre dame prend des sets
peur aussi
je pensais ça pour faire ça du coup et
mettons
sur le film
c'est sur le fil mais du coup ouais bon
il y a peut-être des moyens de tenir
mais en tout cas il faut qu'ils soient
organise avec ces pièces on peut
imaginer un cavalier c'est cette
cavaliers aussi et
voilà pleinement donc ok si dépressif
peut-être il va réussir à s'en sortir
mais pour l'instant j'ai quand même un
pressing dedans
alors aronyan dit on n'a pas vu pas
beaucoup vu depuis le début donc on
s'est arrêté à Italie avec
v6d dessin donc ça c'est à cette
thématique pour justement récupérer un
dessin et je contrôle le pion isolé du
coup donc il va H6 d'abord on a le temps
avant de le récupérer le pion
qui était quand même un problème parce
que là il y avait quand même des cloches
un peu de partout c'est pas évident à
tenir
donc l'affaire
et ensuite il va aller manger le pion le
pion en dessin
donc elle va les prendre elle va les
prendre
il y a eu toutes les deux jouets
et là il faut aussi donc finalement les
blancs enfin les Noirs terminent leur
développement
A5 et blanc continue à mettre la
pression là-haut à 6 Caval le 5
ok tourisme
très belle fixation quand même de
dingeren
dame et puis cette manœuvre qui a des
trois ks-5 c'est joli montré dans toutes
les écoles
à 5 pour empêcher du B6 alors BC c'est
possible de la faire mais c'est quand
même affaiblissant parce qu'après qui
qui en danger après ce prise pour un 6
et une fois qu'on a mis le pion en A5 on
a bloqué un peu sa structure et donc on
peut venir en 5 parce qu'on sait que B6
ça va être dur à faire donc assez sympa
il a nettement amélioré les pièces
c'est dur pour un rognon
en pratique ça peut être difficile à
tenir enfin en tout cas à trouver des
coups donc les Blancs ont une belle
position j'ai un pion isolé mais vous
voyez que quand on est actif avec le
pluriel et ben ça va en fait c'est pas
forcément une faiblesse hein
salut à tous ceux qui arrivent tortue
magique et compagnie et oui bah là je
pense tout fort on voit un petit plus il
va ça va pousser par cette partie à
partir
et pourquoi ici il a pas de C3
[Musique]
je pense avoir BK
du coup il a laissé et là quand même on
voit que le rock noir bon ça reste quand
même solide un peu tout ça mais
attention moi j'ai un peu peur quand
même légèrement quand même l'idée fois 4
regarder tours si un guéri il joue très
très simple j'aime bien mais il a un
style assez chirurgical aussi guéri à la
fois de la simplicité même dans les
positions complexes
de souffrir là si vous comparez les deux
rois vous voyez clairement ce qui se
passe dans la partie quoi
là le rat noir au centre au fur et à
mesure il va se faire un peu à
décortiquer on va forcer un peu des
échanges le roi Nord qui va s'ouvrir il
y aura de mes chèques c'est ça fait des
cils
tu sais alors qu'on n'a pas vu le
résultat encore
petite entorse stouf j'ai parié contre
mon
contre mon poulain normalement mon
collègue de club voilà et du coup je
sais pas ça normalement
j'espère que je vais être récompenser
quand même
[Musique]
on peut être beau joueur mais il y a
quand même des limites bien joué je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord avec toi donc
qu'est-ce qui nous fait du coup on s'est
arrêté tout à l'heure un peu loin donc
là il y a quand même pas mal d'échanges
de pièces donc
il y a une ligne tactique ici assez
compliqué avec un 5 donc déjà juste sur
mon tout en D4
qui serait en fait
mal placé ouais moi j'ai un fou qui
pourra peut-être un jour venir en dessin
soutenu bon même très bien
mais ton fou il vraiment il bute contre
un contre une structure très solide donc
je pense que c'est un peu plus facile à
jouer ouais peut-être un peu plus facile
à jouer
clairement donc le lion on joue à 5 pour
essayer de
fixer le pion ainsi et en vouloir un peu
plus donc il faut prendre les trois
et là il fallait bien calculer parce
qu'il y a plein de cours intermédiaires
de partout je peux faire [ __ ] ici je
peux manger là donc
il est obligé de prendre B6
donc du coup il y a écrit imbé 6 il a
pris en C2 il y a avant de prendre le
fou et ben il a mangé intermédiaire
donc cette tour prend C8 dans prends ici
et maintenant tu reprends cette donc
tout à l'heure on a dit ici que la prise
en D4 pouvait être possible mais qui
aurait sûrement qu'elle va les prendre à
quatre avec du coup des champs
improbassifs ici et une position qui
d'ailleurs même encore pire non j'étais
un peu de la des bêtises parce que là du
coup si la dame bouge il va avoir une
fourchette en 7 heures
et du coup si je mange en assise on m'a
dit aussi qu'il y avait une petite
fourchette cachée
donc du coup il y a eu tour à 4 pour
essayer de manger avec le cavalier les
quatre
tours
qu'est-ce qui se passe je mange là mange
là mange là il y aura ton point c'est 3
et
voir un petit peu comment ça se joue il
y a un pion noir qui est passé
mais je tiens un meilleur contrôle de la
colonne D cette car elle est prank elle
va les prendre tour reprend et Dame des
deux peut-être enfin un job sympa avec
ton DS7
sachant que ce retour C7 soit 6 excès
accès à un échec là-haut qui peut être
intéressant de revenir ici c'est
peut-être pas forcément l'idée
sans truc il y a dû aussi ce qui peut
être un joueur blanc six pour ouvrir un
peu la position
essayez de provoquer un peu les
faiblesses vous voyez ici que Amazon
mais on va voir en tout cas
et salut à tous ceux qui arrivent salut
canard coureur merci pour ton petit mot
ouais c'est un sujet qu'on traite pas
trop parce qu'on n'est pas sur nos
chaînes perso avec avec stouf et que
comme il y a procédure en cours avec
chaise comme et compagnie sur ce sujet
là c'est difficile d'en parler sur une
chaîne qui n'est pas la nôtre voilà donc
on nous a pour nous parler
si vous voulez avoir votre avis vous
venez sur notre chaîne YouTube
et twitch d'ailleurs je vais vous
envoyer un petit peu les réseaux de ça
veut dire que ça va être la pause
bientôt tiens je vais faire un peu en
fait
les pauses si vous voulez c'est un peu
quand on veut
donc si tu veux faire une pause on fait
une pause mais il y a pas de souci moi
je
une fille qui joue pourquoi pas il y
aura faux elle est très forte elle fait
un super tournoi en plus
elle est jeune elle a elle a 15 ans je
crois ou 16 ans
elle est jeune
c'est une future grande star en tout cas
alors je trouve qu'il a un beau site
exactement
le site fait le site fait par par you
mais lui-même
donc voilà si vous voulez si vous voulez
venir sur nos sur nos chaînes
sur nos chaînes respectives donc YouTube
twitch etc n'hésitez pas à venir à venir
nous rendre visite
j'ai raté j'ai raté mon premier saut
mais je me suis bien rattrapé stuff
bon tu l'as écrit au début la première
fois j'ai mis carrément l'URL non j'ai
mis l'URL carrément de toute ta chaîne
derrière le seau et ça ça va marcher ça
marche pas voilà ça marche pas
et ouais bah j'essaie
tous les jours donc n'hésitez pas en
tout cas on a aussi et moi j'ai aussi
une chaîne une chaîne Youtube donc c'est
tout fait chèque en ce moment on se fait
des des speedrun d'ailleurs j'ai perdu
une partie en speed dans mon dernier
speedrun Kevin
c'est la première
que je perds
mais j'ai un épisode qui va sortir ou
peut-être que j'ai perdu souffle donc
si tu veux bon je suis tous les jours en
commentaire ici et le genre de repos
c'était du coup du coup mercredi et j'ai
enchaîné 7 heures de cours
plus un petit stream le soir et bon je
faisais pas forcément de super super
échecs
il y a une partie où mon adversaire a un
beau fou en H5 et moi j'ai une dame en
E2 et un pion en E3 et ben j'ai repris
une pièce en A4 du pion et il m'a
branché ma femme
alors que j'avais une pièce d'avance et
que bah la partie était juste gagnée et
après ça c'était assez marrant parce que
j'ai essayé de l'arnaquer moi j'avais
une dame note de moi et j'ai trouvé des
pâtes des réseaux de pattes très jolies
et malheureusement il est pas tombé
dedans donc on a essayé de de prier hein
pour que ça marche mais ça marche pas
avec le niveau là
donc
c'est vraiment donc j'avais une pièce
d'avant c'était complètement gagnant
j'ai gagné un coup juste j'ai pas fait
attention au courage quoi ah je
comprends mais bon après ça reste
pédagogique malgré tout voilà je voulais
pas perdre mais je t'avouerai que
maintenant je sais que que j'ai perdu
quoi donc tu vois
moi c'est l'autre problème tu sais c'est
je veux discuter des positions je parle
beaucoup et l'histoire c'est que j'ai
plus de temps et je perds quoi tu vois
enfin le drame quoi
et merci Templiers pour le petit mot sur
le site de formation d'ailleurs je vous
mets en plus le lien vers le cadeau si
vous avez envie de découvrir la
plateforme de formation comme Templiers
bah vous y allez je vous mets ça tout de
suite et voilà comme ça vous avez tout
pendant la pause vous allez sur le site
de stouf sur la chaîne YouTube sur la
chaîne twitch vous faites pareil chez
moi et si vous avez envie de regarder la
plateforme de formation bah ça nous fera
plaisir ça nous fera un grand plaisir de
vous retrouver quand
on est quand on est sur le web voilà
voilà ça marche on fait une petite pause
et on vous retrouve après pour une
petite minute pour les quasi note et du
coup je vais te lancer avec vous je vais
mettre une petite vue sympa pour la pose
j'ai une vue sympa pour la pose attends
une seconde je la reprends
ouais
je vais juste vous juste que je vois
quel truc que je fais alors quelle
partie vous voulez voir quelle partie
vous voulez voir quelqu'un qui nous
demandait d'où on était ses fans qui
nous demandait où on était stouf il est
au canari il sera peut-être en Espagne
et prochainement et pour ma part
j'habite à Rennes voilà pour très proche
de Rennes donc je suis breton et je le
revendique alors que stouf c'est l'école
niçoise
j'étais à Nice et à Cannes toute ma vie
je vais vous mettre la vue
c'est en train de se
faire quelque chose de tranquille
mais avec plaisir de ces femmes
donc du coup ce que va vous régaler avec
une petite vue l'aspect technique voilà
il est en train de s'occuper de la régie
et je peux vous annoncer tout à l'heure
on disait carlsan il va pousser machin
je pense qu'il y aura une petite nul
avec Jordan van forest qui a beau être
moins technique que Magnus cette
position
cavalier je mets le fou en B5 je fais
peut-être B4 et je pense qu'il aura du
mal à la perdre voilà
je peux vous laisser là-dessus je pense
sympa pour pour la pub
à l'ancienne
Mozart en fait la coupe Mozart
vous inquiétez pas la régie
non mais c'est super d'être breton c'est
une chance c'est une chance magnifique
magnifique
en lui ouais bon du coup la caméra qui
est revenue donc du coup je vous dis à
tout de suite je vais couper les micros
puis on va ensemble allez à tout de
suite à tout de suite
et nous sommes revenus avec Kevin hello
à tous yes donc pour cette deuxième
partie on va dire de
donc on va faire un petit tour
rapidement on va voir ce qui s'est passé
dans ce tournoi qui viennent donc on a
on a découvertes
on pense qu'on va assister à une à une
belle nulle
il vient de simplifier avec un très joli
coup B4
Jordan van forest je voulais faire
foudre et franchement
c'est c'est plutôt sympa ce qui est en
train de se passer pour lui dans
l'optique de ne pas perdre en tout cas
il y a eu des échanges massifs et on le
voit on va on va arriver sur le dernier
coup jouer B4 après B4 et maintenant on
va pouvoir jouer 5 par exemple suivi de
Tours BK4 voilà donc
elle est assez égale à moins que les
Noirs arrivent à jouer ici G4 un jour et
tout ouvrir et manger un peu défiant
mais bon j'y crois pas trop trop en plus
cadeau donc c'est la partie et là j'ai
faux B3
alors pour le fou mais bon je trouvais
ça plus naturel faut baisser
ok
c'est parce qu'on avait dit on avait dit
qu'elle tour de 7 et donc là Kevin
proposait de tour des 8 qui a l'air pas
mal mais
tourner
8 il faut prendre des huit dames des 7
tu sais c'était embêtant mais j'avais
aussi Dame des cinq
donc c'était pas si simple
les deux coups ont l'air assez solide
donc on va avoir un peu ce qu'il est
possible de faire un truc on n'est pas
possible il y a un clouage sur la dame
et après tour des 8 échanger un peu des
pièces
l'attaque blanche voilà c'est ça
un jeu possible avec la valise C5 on se
disait que c'était sans doute mieux
et c'est un peu difficile facile pour
les blancs en plus de jouer les coups
du coup cabano7 prise dans le 3 et là il
y a clairement un problème sur sur ce
pion aussi
maintenant il y a un bon travail sur le
pion aussi mais c'est joli ce qu'ils ont
fait les noirs pour quand vous êtes
moins bien il faut trouver une solution
dynamique et le 20e coup cavalier E7
pour chambouler un peu la position c'est
franchement une bonne décision de la
part de Lévana rognan qui est
extrêmement fort mais il essaie d'être
moins mal et trouve de contre jeu
qui va arriver le pion aussi ce qui est
un peu en souffrance donc il y a une
pression pour les blancs mais après ça
va être compliqué parce que il est vrai
que quand le pion tombera et ben
peut-être que celui-là tombera aussi
donc ça risque de se réaliser un petit
peu au centre où je peux répondre à
tonton aide qui m'a dit qu'il arrive à
comprendre comment on sait que ça va
faire nul je peux revenir à la position
dans le Forest Carson rapidement
en fait tout simplement le plus on va le
récupérer donc on a on va avoir quatre
pions contre quatre pions d'accord
le pion a il va quand même avoir du mal
à avancer j'ai quand même une tour qui
bloque une autre tour qui bloque ici en
fait le pion a pas trop comment il va
avancer pour l'instant et là j'ai quatre
contre trois et puis on va avancer pour
s'échanger un petit peu nous on
considère que au final les pièces vont
se changer et que il y a pas vraiment de
moyens de passer quoi
maintenant
c'est vrai qu'il y a encore du temps à
tonton rage comprends que la nul soit
pas signé tout de suite après à leur
niveau c'est le genre de position
typique qu'on a vu maintes et maintes
fois où ça fait nul relativement
facilement il y a quelques contre
exemples de temps en temps donc on se
méfie quand même même par exemple
si tu prends ici
bon déjà si tu prends là
et il y a tout emprise là c'est cloué
etc
à 4 c'est dommage voilà et si je prends
ici ben tu as juste pour B8 et on va
échanger une tour et après je pourrais
changer dehors etc donc avoir quoi avoir
en tout cas même tu auras 5
ou un peu de tout les blancs qui jouent
pour le gain à un moment si jamais
j'arrive à Rouen mettre mon roi que du
pion consolider un peu etc il y a
toujours les blancs qui peuvent avoir un
petit pressing mais sinon franchement
non car c'est ne sera jamais ça et on
peut imaginer que les noirs peuvent pas
trop je pour gagner que les blancs vont
pas non plus faire l'un ils sont très
techniques dans ces phases de jeu
ils vont pas se laisser
avoir donc du coup ouais je pense que
nul à valeur assez logique donc cette
partie du coup de guéri contre ergazi ou
gris mettez une grosse grosse pression
sur le Roi noir
donc on s'est arrêté un peu par là donc
on avait eu B3
ça on l'avait vu et on s'est arrêté du
coup à
4 et dans cette pollution et regardez
qui avait beaucoup de temps à jouer et
il a fini par jouer ici le coup H6
fois H4
je sais pas si j'ai envie d'enfermer mon
foulard ou de le ramener en des deux
les deux coups ont l'air cool en tout
cas
clairement
H4 faudra analyser des histoires de Tour
Eiffel 4
est-ce que c'est vraiment un coup ou pas
parce que il y a peut-être fou prendre
c'est compliqué c'est position là
c'est une pièce qui par exemple
mais je pense que c'est la meilleure
chance pour je préfère fouder deux pour
être stable je souffre après c'est des
questions je pense que les deux sont
jouables et fous des deux ça assure le
coup j'ai l'impression mais l'idée de
faire [ __ ] j'aime bien aussi parce que
du coup
tu as un vis-à-vis et puis maintenant
une fois que j'ai fait faux H4 et ben il
faut prendre 5 devient tout à fait
logique
je pense que dans cette position il faut
vraiment jouer tout rêve 4 c'est sur X4
pour pour essayer l'histoire actuelle
pour jouer un peu compliqué ouais c'est
ça
mater quoi tout simplement et roi B8 a
été joué dans cette position où c'est
pas moi qui l'ai fait donc ça ça semble
un peu bizarre encore une fois parce
qu'on se met ici mais peut-être qu'il
veut
maintenant que le fou peut plus venir en
E3 et que le flou blanc il est parti
sans fermer ici et ben il considère que
son rang sera en sécurité on a 7
on a vu la jauge n'avait pas aimé mais
je trouve que l'idée humainement elle
est très intéressante
[Musique]
mais
essayez de tu vois il y a un peu de
contrôle
il faut il faut voir un mais c'est quand
même justement ce qu'on veut d'ailleurs
s'intéressant qu'on intègre grâce à toi
on voit les complications secrets et
c'est pour ça que les coups stables avec
les Blancs
ça paraît tranquille après faut H4 fou
G3 c'est relativement stable et j'aurais
préféré jouer cette position avec tout
recadre et mettre
et
c'est sûr que les blancs sont mieux mais
c'est un peu plus casse-gueule je trouve
cette position tout à l'heure après bon
c'est chaud c'est chaud mais
on voit encore
je peux toujours faire des choses
ça reste ça reste celui au centre
en tout cas partie très ambitieuse de
regga Easy mais
il joue très juste un tournoi
merci pour ton petit mot
ok alors ensuite on a
contre Prague donc comme je le disais
tout à l'heure il a réussi à manger le
pion à 6 alors comment est-ce qu'il a
fait
il a fait Dame des deux
d'un prend C3 et du coup il y a pas de
prendre les deux de vis-à-vis en E5
parce que je dois prendre 5 tout
simplement
donc
en fait le pion va être perdu au final
donc le pion est perdu mais le pion de 5
est bloqué
7 tu en as 4 et on va un peu harceler la
dame alors l'histoire c'est que si on
arrivait dans la finale de tours après
des échanges massifs le tour 4 contre
tour 3 ne gagnerait pas déjà on peut
vous le dire faudrait que les Noirs
jouent achète à chaque
donc déjà les
Noirs en fait sont assez d'accords de
liquider on peut faire n'importe quoi
non plus mais
beaucoup de finale sont nuls ici enfin
de tour donc c'est un des objectifs de
la position noire en plus de rester
dynamique parce que forcément on a le
moins donc faut pas lâcher initiative en
plus d'avoir le pied de moi
donc c'est un rentre dans ce dans cette
idée là
F4 qui doit faire
répétition à moins de faire de ma faim
parce que à la tour qui rentre en C1
mais bon enfin ce serait hyper compliqué
là il faut que je tourne un truc comme
ça
actif de coup les blancs peuvent pas
trop se barrer donc on se fait un peu
harcelé c'est pas évident techniquement
on est content d'avoir le pion de plus
mais comment on va le valoriser ça c'est
des nœuds à la tête
c'est pas facile de progresser vous le
voyez
ok du coup rapport paraam donc là on
s'est arrêté un petit Caballe et prend
un F6 qui avait eu
avec je prends un F6
ou 3 et ici là je tourne vite donc il
est pas pressé en fait en dessin que je
peux juste te faire [ __ ] maintenant tu
as par rapport à tout à l'heure par
exemple
sans doute que ces quatre c'est un coup
que j'ai envie de faire oui il y a mon
cavalier E5 enfin il y a beaucoup de
cours à regarder autour de 8 c'est assez
intelligent
oui on va pas le jouer tout de suite
mais petit rock à 6
et C4 on a pas le temps parce qu'elle
est leviers B5 et F5 sans doute F5 très
très pénible donc la structure E4 c'est
4 c'est les taux de maroczi de la
sylliane on peut jouer ce type de coût
seulement
lorsque les noirs n'ont pas les leviers
parce que quand les Noirs ont les levier
ça explose complètement et là la
position serait vraiment très saine très
belle pour les noirs avec toutes les
pièces actives
tout reprend aussi sa quel moment on
peut regarder tout reprendre
[Musique]
on a eu assisté à tourner le coup
logique je pense avec des blancs
sauf on n'a pas le temps de faire
cailler des deux qui a eu 4 cavalier F6
comme dans un rêve avec un petit H4 etc
ça pourrait être génial mais j'ai pas le
temps de faire tout ça
donc on va voir en tout cas mais bon ça
a l'air puis en plus pour les blancs
mais c'est pas simple de gagner les
noirs qui veulent changer les pièces
blanc qui vont essayer de garder les
pièces en essayant de ramener à la fin
de monter leur attaque
avoir comment ça se passe
du coup on disait par un rapport star
était là donc
c'est 8 qui avaient les mettre
le pion décide il est plutôt faible mais
j'ai un carré dans la cinquième qui
tient bien
et du coup la pollution elle est pas si
mauvaise pour la noire
et B5 a été joué par les Noirs par rame
donc moi j'aime bien le noir je trouve
que c'est une position intéressante oui
c'est intéressant après c'est toujours
un peu plus un petit peu plus agréable
je dirais pour les blancs du fait du
pion des 5 quand même des 6 qui ne peut
pas aller en dessin justement et la case
des 5 bon il y a pas trop de risques
même fousser 4 c'est pas de problème
c'est un peu du mal à accéder à accéder
à la cadette des cinq avec les Blancs
pour l'instant
disons que c'est le fou G7 je vois pas
encore comment on va pouvoir l'activer
donc c'est ce bémol là qui fait que je
préfère un petit peu les blancs
sinon j'ai pas d'idée pour se fouger 7
alors que bon l'architecture des pièces
blanches n'est pas elles sont pas très
bonnes on voit pas trop pourquoi elles
sont sur tel ou tel case mais j'ai
l'impression que je peux les recycler
plus facilement et se fout j'essaie de
me faire peur
c'est vrai que les pièces noires
tiennent bien la boutique pour l'instant
qu'elle va lui E5 ou C4 dames et 7 tours
assez naturel chez les Noirs mais il y a
même maintenant plus trop
d'améliorations alors que les blanches
je pense que ça s'améliore un peu plus
voilà bon après avoir
comme on va faire et je suis obligé de
surveiller la poussée de D5 noir aussi
un moment il faut pas que
faut pas que ça se fasse trop vite
yes
ok ok alors du coup la dernière partie
qui nous restait à avoir ce coup ça à
partir de car voilà contre Google
ou du coup on disait au début ça fait
vraiment on n'est pas venu voir on
parlait de B3 et on faisait du coup
c'est 5 c'était difficile à jouer parce
que du coup le fou donc ça va se
réveiller et il ajoute 5
préparer la poussée c'est simple et du
coup à ce moment là
libérer le fou de casse noir en C3 j'ai
envie de dire que d'un côté ben il
fallait quand même faire quelque chose
avec les mains
je chantais pas du tout cette position
pour pour Google je parce que c'est une
position typique ou on a plus de foot
casse noir et que la seule percée c'est
c'est 5
moi j'aurais peut-être essayé cavalier
le cas dans ce type de position stuff
alors attends il y a peut-être de la
tactique avec puis on prend des 5 je
sais pas faut regarder mais
ça m'embête quand même de faire ces cinq
parce qu'on ouvre la case noire alors
qu'on n'a pas le foot 15 noire
normalement
à l'école des échecs c'est pas c'est pas
apprécié ce genre de réaction quand même
vous voyez la réaction stratégique c'est
5 c'est logique pour le centre mais il
est logique parce qu'on donne les cases
noires au blanc qui sont les seuls à
avoir le foot 15 novembre on avait parlé
un sous-sol pas courement jouer cette
position
c'était basé sur le fait que comme il
avait joué cavalier cette rapidement il
connaissait bien la pose et en fait il a
été il a été embarrassé ici
et ça fait plusieurs parties quand même
que Google fait des trucs un peu bizarre
tu vois c'est vrai on avait la partie
contre Ding par exemple où il avait fait
un peu bizarre
et là du coup il est un peu en
difficulté
il se dit peut-être que du coup elle va
il va voir du contre-jour et puis on C4
et sur le roi
l'objectif a changé sauf maintenant du
de notre jeu de case noire on a gagné un
pion sur le roi noir et maintenant
l'objectif change le plan change c'est
ma télé roi noir et très joli H4 de
Fabiano Caruana qui fait une énorme
partie c'est ça
dame revient pour les menaces
et puis en plus net et le roi déchiré
une leçon pour l'instant de Fabienne au
carwana qui sort une énorme partie et
vous cache une toute petite partie
on rappelle on dit pas qu'on ferait
mieux mais c'est juste que ben là il
prend une baie il se fait bien bouger
elle est magnifique la partie de carwana
il pique le foot 15 noire il déchire le
roi et il commence à embêter le roi et
il garde son pion de plus c'est bon
des plus grands espoirs au monde de plus
de 2700
nouveaux joueurs de Mulhouse d'ailleurs
vous cache tu me l'avais dit tout donc
bah là il est en train de se faire
bouger mais carwana c'est pas le premier
venu ex numéro 2 mondial voilà avec un
très très gros vélo Fabiano a été 28 30
et quelques soufs quelque chose comme ça
je crois qu'il a eu encore à 28 35
je crois que c'est je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est rognon il a dû avoir
plus que ça encore je crois
en tout cas bon c'est salut à tous
un tournoi je crois que c'était
je vais dire ça le record virtuel
encore virtuel Carona
[Musique]
carwana très simple en plus
je vais mieux regarder le système avec
chaque il a qu'il a joué c'est d'une
simplicité enfantine j'ai l'impression à
jouer tu joues dans ma classe et chaque
tu me le cailles en C6 tu sors tes
pièces et
et après on joue aux échecs franchement
superbe
j'ai adoré cette partie courage 4 avec
tour G4 échec qui peut arriver bien sûr
ça n'a pas envie de prendre G2 non
5 et il y a peut-être une petite un
petit F3 en récompense à la fin aussi
je pouvais peut-être même le jouer
directement sous ce F3 vicieux agro F2
je sais pas ça me fait rigoler de jouer
un coup comme ça
faut pas prendre un match avec Dame G3
dames C8 en G3
un petit un petit plaisir à l'ancienne
en tout cas c'est très beau ce qu'on
vient de voir là dans cette partie
il y a 40 points et l'eau entre les deux
joueurs mais
on a une pépite Google contre un des
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux de tous les
temps qui a une expérience phénoménale
carwana donc du coup même ça paraît
équilibré sur le papier en plus c'est
qu'un ruana qui a les pièces blanches
donc c'est des arguments pour la
pression
c'est quand même Caruana quasiment à son
plus bas et bukache au plus haut donc
c'est quand même pas tout à fait les
mêmes joueurs mais c'est pas pour rien
qu'on avait
qu'on avait mis dans le pronostic car on
a gagné
assez loin
non mais dans l'eau
pronostics d'aujourd'hui là ah oui oui
c'est vrai
tu l'as mis 9
je regrette un petit peu ce que je suis
en train de constater
cette partie aujourd'hui alors du coup
on va revenir peut-être si tu veux sur
sur 45
faut mettre la caméra qui va avec
caméra scène
ici qui a les Noirs donc on disait que
cette position on pensait qu'elle allait
parmiée par la lune donc il y a eu H4
qui bloque au final un petit peu tu vois
la structure des blancs
et du coup
les blancs peuvent plus trop se créer
puis bah c'est F4 peut être une
possibilité mais est-ce que je pense pas
un très bon coup parce que
les noirs qui vont essayer d'aller
croquer le petit pion en G2
pour
pour aller
essayer de gagner après manger le pion
H3 donc c'est pas du tout possible de
VF4
faut pas l'oublier bien sûr on n'oublie
pas on a dit que c'était un des
meilleurs
espoirs au monde voir le meilleur bon
donc du coup il y en a d'autres mais
franchement très très fort
bon là bon on va assister à notre petite
nul
c'est même plus agréable à jouer côté
blanc parce qu'on a le pion passé alors
que le 4 contre 3 pour l'instant on n'a
pas abouti
tous les joueurs passent au travers sur
une partie surtout avec les noirs et
surtout contre un gars comme karwan mais
franchement la partie carburana est très
très qualitative
ce que l'on aime avec avec tout c'est
les parties un peu d'école là c'est
linéaire on a vu tout prendre des
petites notes sur les jolies parties bah
celle-là par rapport au jeu de couleur
elle est sympa
Prague non non il y en a il y a beaucoup
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui arrivent
du coup un bon tournoi aussi là il y a
eu ce qu'on avait dit d'ailleurs dans la
partie de Prague il y a eu tout reprend
le tour et dames et deux
voilà et puis les Noirs pressent alors
que les Blancs ont un bon pion de plus
et du coup du coup voilà
voir comment on continue
ça peut faire un peu peur avec d'un bien
et
pas sur ma tête non plus tu vois par
exemple là je pense à ça
pour faire tourner ça fait un peu peur
de voir que moi aussi les idées c'est
que là haut ici et ici et le roi il est
un petit peu abandonné mais elle donne
envie c'est c'est variantes mais avec
Souf ça nous est déjà arrivé de nous
faire piéger en rentrant dans le camp et
demi comme ça on investit nos pièces et
on sait très bien que si on mate pas on
se fait avoir et ça tout le monde l'a
vécu d'envoyer les pièces
pour ça
mais attention
ça veut pas dire que ça marche à tous
les coups faut vraiment que les pièces
après arrivent
donc grosse volonté là il veut gagner
Abdou
mais ça va être dur ça va être dur alors
en termes de timing prime d'un 14
minutes il sera pas en danger autant au
niveau du contrôle temps très bonne
gestion du temps et Abdou qui a joué
très vite
la plus
indécise guéri peut-être un parce que
avec digne qui est en train de presser
mais guéri c'est le
allez on va enfin celle-là je vais
mettre la caméra qui va avec
trois jouets
attention c'est une position on guérit
c'est sûr qu'il est mieux parce qu'il a
un roi vraiment à l'abri mais attention
pion des 5 et 4 ça peut complètement
avancer mets de la
est magnifique vu là que nous a proposé
stuff à la technique vous a fait un
petit montage
j'ai mis ce clic non mais c'est très
bien franchement on était pas mal cette
cam je pense pour les spectateurs
j'ai bien aimé j'aime bien
officielle des pauses
mais c'est là où j'ai mes 18 came
tout mélangées du coup
la vue elle est passée
c'est pas si mal honnêtement de sécurité
avec une petite musique derrière comme
le public aime et alors tout le monde
est ravi
bon vous voyez pourquoi cette partie
nous plaît plus que les autres
bah c'est les recomposer avec un roi
noir dans les courants d'air mais en
même temps il va se planquer en A7 c'est
ce que
are Younes nous a raconté quand il a
joué roi B8 pour mettre son roi à 7
et en contrepartie de ce roi fragile en
danger il a les pions des 5 et C4 qui à
un moment pourrait se mettre en marche
pour aller gagner la partie maintenant
il faut laisser passer l'orage et c'est
pas dit qu'il
n'est pas mal très prochainement c'est
très dur de mettre partir des pions
comme ça ça donne des cases chaque fois
tout est faible sacrifice qui sont
possibles le renard qui est vraiment
vraiment faible je suis retour aussi ça
à tempo j'ai envie de jouer de ces
femmes tout rêve D1 je pense touf ça a
l'air normal on joue à tempo Fd1 pour
améliorer la pièce qui ne joue pas
derrière s'en fout
laissant ainsi aussi
sur le site on peut bouger la dame en C6
par exemple et vous voyez la petite
arnaque c'est que si on joue aussi
peut-être qu'on perd l'option
ou en tout cas les sous pressions
ici mettre un Cavaillon des 4 plus tard
éventuellement
c'est dur quand même pour
pour les noirs
des 1 ça c'est à peu près sûr et sur un
schéma kb6 peut-être un moment jouer un
A4 qu'on aurait le droit de faire un 4
dans la position
j'aime bien en A5 attaques là tu
attaques un peu là aussi
[Musique]
en plus on s'enlève comme du vis-à-vis
de la tour
donc ça nous permet de faire des trucs
des fois des fois du 6 sans problème sur
la dame qui pourra venir en A4 moi
j'aime beaucoup Dame des deux avoir
[Musique]
en tout cas ton rêve D1 c'est sûr alors
je sais pas il a pas joué encore mais
ça a l'air tout à fait logique en tout
cas et après vous continuez avec un jeu
sauf pour poser Dame des deux damasak on
part A4 on joue sur les mêmes idées de
faire ma adversaire en tout cas et on
est quand même pas loin du chaos j'ai
l'impression
ça laisse toute la souplesse alors que
tout Fd1 voyez j'aime bien dire aux
élèves tout vous activez votre moins
bonne pièce pour moi c'était la Tour
Eiffel qui n'avait pas le droit de
bouger et
guéri fait une adaptation de ses
principes basiques qu'il connaît et il
dit Dame des deux c'est plus concret
parce que j'attaque des cinq sur kb6 il
avait vu ton damasin qui presse vraiment
encore plus vite
à cause du vis-à-vis
cavalier B6 et là est-ce qu'on fait
damassingue je pense que oui
une fois que tu bouges
aussi hein
qui arrive pas forcément envie de te
donner les fous on va c'est vraiment
tout nu sur le gaz noir donc t'as pas
envie de c'est pas vraiment une défense
j'ai l'impression
du coup très très dur la pose très très
vieux alors Carlsen ils ont changé une
tour
et du coup le roi qui va venir en G2
alors du coup attention qu'une fois que
Laura arrive en G3
il y a toujours des petits problèmes
pratiques avec éventuellement
un pressing sur le pion G2
je commence à je commence à aimer un peu
les noirs pour te dire la vérité
c'est un problème quand des fois on joue
la nul et ben quand on joue trop la nul
et ben
ça peut nous faire en fait
perdre des parties Kevin le fait de trop
vouloir
le fait de trop vouloir échanger des
pièces pour forcer un peu la nul ou des
choses comme ça il va des fois on finit
par parfois des mauvais goûts et prendre
de mauvaises décisions etc
pour il faut partir à un moment donné
pour voilà c'est ce qu'il a fait
voilà c'est ça
je peux me prendre pour des 7 mais pour
l'instant à 5 c'est sécurisé
ça va être encore une belle finale on
nous l'avait dit dans le chat ça va être
encore il y avait encore du travail de
toute façon personne va essayer de
pousser un peu c'est clair
on sait pas ce qui va gagner mais en
tout cas il va être la pousser un petit
peu il fera pas d'annuler rapide comme
ça
ok
en plus au niveau du 2 c'était ma
position d'avant
c'était un Peugeot
là vous voyez on est au 35e coups ils
sont encore beaucoup de temps la banlie
tous les deux donc je pense que
ce serait pas il y aura pas de direct
note là ici ils ont 27 minutes contre 20
et la toucher il a touché sa structure
un G6
parce que je prends là le problème c'est
qu'il y a le pionchisme maintenant à
tout moment on s'y en l'air en plus du
reste
manger
il faut être
eux aussi
et c'est un peu dur donc là c'est juste
trouver un coup effectivement
en finale
les Noirs ont leur chance parce qu'ils
ont trois contre deux
la problématique c'est que je vais me
faire fixer avec le coupe B3
c'est même toi qui joue presque pour le
gars
alors oui en fait j'avais pas vu mais tu
en as comme un mais j'ai qu'à lui en
pire voilà donc j'ai trois
[Musique]
je peux manger et jouer à 4 et B3 etc
et là on va voir un peu je crois que
c'est ce qui s'est passé
prise d'un point ok intéressant la prise
décision de caméra parce que hyper un
pion mais la le fait d'avoir un pion
noir en B4 ça change quand même pas mal
les choses au niveau de la structure tu
vois
jouer apparemment il a fait un coup qui
lui fait perdre tout son avantage
[Musique]
je change d'avis d'accord parce qu'en
fait vu que le coup noir dame Cécile
elle a bien peut-être que tu vois une
idée de dame B5 en fait contre Damas 5
peut être une idée intéressante pour du
coup
ça empêche d'amsiste tout ça et ça
menace aussi des cavaliers les cinq
donc du coup on peut voir dans ma salle
pour voir si j'avais le timing pour le
jouer ou pas on va voir la journée
c'est vraiment rigolo
en fait je voulais faire tout rêve bien
pour profiter de ta dame en fait il y a
fou prendre des cas pour prendre des cas
d'un B5
et là oui là
donc avaler des cartes on peut
comprendre non mais peut-être qu'il y a
des cadres comme ça on est
c'est très stable après qu'il y avait
des cartes ça ça bouge pas en face
peut-être j'aime bien aussi c'est
peut-être le coup j'en sais rien mais il
est vrai qu'après aussi
d'un bouge je perce tonton
envie de le faire c'est quand même ton
pion que tu vois
et genre un truc comme ça quoi
bon ça a l'air compliqué quand même pour
les Noirs c'est très très dur en
pratique
en pratique il faudra être précis
pour les deux grands
normale
pour vous dire je pense que faut
attendre en plus comme tu l'as dit on
peut jouer ça et ça quoi donc puis même
avantage il a l'air préférer un coup je
sais pas donc c'est peut-être
juste
la jauge même c'est toujours le bon coup
elle va descendre montrer etc
pour penser qu'à toi de 10 pièces
différentes
il est à plus de en tournoi il va pas
commencer à
ok donc à 4 avril c'est quand même du
sens hein
donc ici
il y a toujours un bon plus hein
dans un ordre différent on avait le
tiercé mais pas dans le bonheur Dame des
deux à quatre tours FDA on avait que le
mauvais ordre c'est ça et
un petit coup là le pion4 qui veut
devenir prenable à un moment qu'elle va
les prendre de 5
ça fait peur quand même hein
n'a pas trop envie de faire ça
qui des fois il croit pas trop trop
que pourrait faire
donc
vous arrivez 20 pour se permettre un roi
à huit comme ça et regalizi déjà il
avait mis en grand enfin il avait joué
grand rock puis après il a joué roi B8
et il se trouve qu'il doit calculer
toutes les suites pour pas se faire
avoir un stuff sinon ils peuvent vite
perdre cette partie il y a beaucoup de
calcul c'est un jeu d'équilibre histoire
[Musique]
voilà et bah il faut pas reproduire ça à
la maison pour autant là c'est vraiment
du jeu de pointe
tu vois de bouffer à 4 mais il y va
donc sans doute à valider de sous tout à
l'heure dans ma 5 dame B5
et là moi j'ai mangé des cinq c'est trop
trop mauvais ou ça donne envie hein
je garde mon pion
voilà c'est de si je prends il y a
si je prends prends
je t'enlève tes bonnes pièces et en
enlevant les mauvaises de mon côté mais
bon ouais c'est chaud
pourquoi il a pas pris avec la dame on
pense qu'il y avait tout un tourbé un
de ses fans tourin qui attaqué la dame
avec un pressing encore plus important
j'y croyais pas trop
attaquer
est-ce que je peux te laisser Kevin
juste 3 minutes
je te laisse la position j'arrive
c'est en plus une position il reste 13
coups ils ont 20 minutes chacun 18 et 22
position hyper hyper tendue qui joue
dans dessin avec les Blancs la
problématique d'échanger les dames c'est
que le roi à 8 ça y est il est sécurisé
et si je ne le fais pas il faut quelque
chose de très concret parce que je viens
de bazarder un pion parce qu'en plus le
cavalier qui vient d'arriver en A4 c'est
des C3 potentiels et bref c'est les
pions noirs qui pourraient avancer donc
pas facile à négocier
l'autre coup qu'on pourrait regarder ici
c'est peut-être
tout simplement tour à un comme sur dame
prend A4 du reste avec l'idée de
tourindames et deux
donc là je peux plus faire les flèches
c'est ça le truc donc toi
quel cavalier il y a pas de bonne case
pour le cavalier et je veux mettre la
pression sur A6
et toi ça pourrait amplifier les dames
en D5 voilà pas tout un jouet c'est
normal moi c'était vraiment le coup qui
qui faisait mal ok donc il y a une
double idée on a dit dams2 suivi d'un
cran des 5 les deux voilà
même tu reprends un cap d'apprendre des
5 donc là du coup tour à prendre un
cadre d'un point de 5 bien jouer matador
très bon en fait on a les deux sens dame
prend des cinq là ça fait mal matador
nous dit tout reprend un 4 d'un point 1
4 dames prends des cinq échecs gagne le
fou gagne le fou en vrai ouais ça doit
ça doit le faire gaffe matador il y a la
tour des en l'air mais si c'est roi A7
il y aura dame français 5 échecs donc là
multi menace en fait
Erika ici il est pas du tout tiré
d'affaires
même s'il joue très correctement même si
on a vu la jauge sexy
ce qui Annie je guéri avait fait dame
prend des seins qui s'en sortait dans la
finale je pense par contre tu auras un
c'est un pressing monumental
donc du coup c'est pour moi c'est
quasiment
est-ce que c'est quasiment défaite c'est
extrêmement dur en tout cas
avec 16 minutes à moins qu'il ait vu
quelque chose là
il est en difficulté
grande difficulté
je pense que
il faut être très très bon ici avec les
noirs pour trouver un contrôle jeu et
bien sûr un coup comme tour pro F3 un
sacrifice de qualité de marchera
absolument pas je les prends F3 il se
passe rien
[Musique]
j'ai quand même une idée autour de cela
c'est tout reprend f3g pour F3 qui me
permettrait de faire des 4 mais il y a
toujours le problème de dams et deux je
pense
madame c'est deux cavaliers ces trois
peut-être
si je joue ça c'est incroyable alors
tout reprend F3 je prends F3 D4 j'essaie
si vous voulez de trouver quelque chose
d'un petit peu particulier avec
avec les Noirs parce que sinon j'ai
l'impression que je vais perdre tout de
suite
il y a des coups un peu plus sage
je joue potentiellement roi à 7 pour
essayer de densifier le pion A6 et sur
dame c'est 2 cavalier B6 sur Damas 2
cavalier 3
donc peut-être roi à 7 pour pour
défendre le pion assis mais il y a
toujours les problèmes de d'apprent des
dans ce sens-là ça reste pénible
peut-être tout reprend F3 et D4 j'ai pas
vu la réfutation pour l'instant tout
reprend F3 et D4 et ça paraît bizarre
c'est hyper bancal mon histoire ah oui
tout reprend F3 D4 donc tout reprend
f3g.f3 D4 Damas 5 et Damas 5
ça attaque le cavalier A4 ça prend à 6
peut-être encore cavalier C3 mais c'est
très très limite
j'ai l'impression que c'est très
compliqué
[Musique]
ces trois pics cavaliers B2
C3
pas pourquoi pas ces trois c'est trois
peut-être juste
Dame des trois ou deux
avec beaucoup de problèmes on est en
train d'essayer de trouver quelque chose
pour arionner egaliser tout fait on
galère
c'est énorme là je
pourrai 8 B8 a été proposé
j'ai pas envie de mettre le cavalier en
baie de toute façon et pourquoi pas trop
envie de quelques coups
c'est dur à souple à la position
pourquoi pas de toute façon il existe un
acrobate
c'est un acrobate il aime beaucoup les
pollutions qui tiennent à un fil tu as
vu contre
pas simple
j'ai pas réussi à le réfuter mais ça ça
sent pas bon
il y a peut-être tout simplement
d'ailleurs
sécurité
oui c'était plus je voulais balancer je
voulais essayer de faire un contre jeu
en balançant mes deux pions et j'ai
besoin de te faire tourner froid pour
pousser des cartes et j'essaie de
pousser mes pieds mais mon roi est
faible
[Musique]
pour éclater les chaînes de pions et
faire mal le problème c'est que notre
Roi noir il est déjà éclaté
en pratique ça m'a l'air trop trop dur
pour noir je
sais pas
parce qu'en fait en plus il y a dams de
Damas de Damas hein qui a regardé dame
prend des 5 ça fait quatre coups qu'il
faut regarder à chaque fois dans toutes
les lignes
donc en plus d'être difficile sans doute
c'est dur à calculer
donc je galère énormément tout pour
trouver un coup
c'est
une bonne proposition mais est-ce que ça
tient vraiment
donc si c'est vrai que si je joue
d'imprends descendre tu auras toujours
l'histoire du match de couloir pour
tenir la pose
je pense que la finale c'est moindre
malin pour
noir noir qui est en plus ici
et je voulais faire sur tour B4
cavaliers des 4
mais il y a peut-être fou prendre B4
tour B8
moi je sais pas c'est chaud
ouais j'ai prévu de tout reprendre à 4
mais en fait tu me fais tu me fais
[ __ ] des cartes c'est ça
quand même tu reprends ainsi ouais c'est
fou ça peut être vraiment très chaud
donc alors faut trouver un coup sur ce
Tour B8 je suis d'accord avec grâce la
touffe qui avait proposé ce très beau
tour B8 mais en plus ça a été joué mais
c'est vraiment typique de réghasi il est
c'est vraiment un acrobate c'est typique
du genre du joueur qui va te manger des
pions et tout défendre en restant hyper
actif comme ça mais bon ça tient à un
fil hein sa position
du coup est-ce qu'on peut rejouer le
thème cavalier des cartes de tout à
l'heure
du coup
c'est possible parce que
c'est de retour
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que ça se passe pas
bien
[Musique]
ma news gagne je suis pas sûr mais on va
on va aller voir ce que propose Magnus
Booba franchement Magnus il était pas
trop en train de gagner il faisait un
petit pressing alors que il y avait pas
grand chose il a réussi à trouver des
ressources pour mettre un petit pressing
en place
est-ce que ça suffira pour gagner
c'était pas notre discours au départ
après non je pense toujours étonnant ce
qu'il arrive à faire on va voir s'il a
réussi à pousser un petit peu on peut
faire un petit tour
ça a vraiment énormément avancé
mais en fait
et ça ça va sacrifier la moment donné ça
suffira là ok à voir alors déjà on va
prendre les deux
moi je vais manger les je vais pousser
lui ça c'est mon idée mais lui il va me
pousser là moi je mets ma tour derrière
mais surtout à cette tour à 5 le pion
bouge plus
mais je peux monter mon roi quand je
rentre mon roi là ton partira à monter
mon roi et sûrement qu'à un moment donné
la tour de voir sacrifier sur le pion
pendant ce temps là nous on va manger
ici on va revenir là on va pousser le
pion et si on fait la même chose bon au
final mon Roi a quand même est quand
même plus proche du pion blanc qu'on va
manger ici et pour pousser les pions ici
tu vois
donc j'ai envie de dire que
[Musique]
c'est plutôt bonne soirée ce qui est en
train d'essayer de jeu pour la nuit ici
de tournage c'est pas forcément bon et
généralement je viens plus actif avec
toi là voilà
je suis en train de m'amuser à regarder
F4 ici
c'était au coup d'avance mais ok
[Musique]
mais et après on reprend H3 faire
quelque chose comme tout reprend G5
c'est rigolo ce genre de thème
donc tourger cette reprise vous vous
voyez un il y a l'histoire de la tour à
5 en l'air
donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais
sinon en thème simple c'est calculer les
courses bon avant de Forest on n'a aucun
entière il a récupéré tout son temps
donc entend dire qu'il va nous faire
preuve de précision ici
belle partie de Magnus Carlsen
aujourd'hui mais ce sera sans doute pas
suffisant pour s'imposer là il faut
beaucoup calculer en fait là c'est que
du calcul
et je pense que les poux sont quasiment
forcés chez les Blancs parce que je vois
pas trop ce qu'il peut faire à part roi
B3
[Musique]
qui gagnerait quoi
ouais mais ça serait sans doute nul pour
le coup parce que je prends H4 quoi
oui effectivement bon mais bon c'est
mais voilà donc en gros le seul coupon
ça va être ça je pense parler bien sûr
il y avait tourgé ça aussi sauf que je
regardais tout reprendre
si moi je fais rien il y a tout reprend
un chèque tout reprend un chèque enfin
tu reprends et dame du coup là je vais
peut-être manger ici
à manger ici
et sur la prise là si je mange ici et
ben il y a dame mais là je mange là
maintenant et là j'ai un pion de plus
j'ai mon roi actif et j'ai un pion qui
peut avancer donc j'ai trouvé un
meilleur coup que ce qu'on a fait parce
que là on va perdre mais en fait on fait
roi ces trois-là
c'est plus un truc marrant hein
bah du coup il y a le pion qui va
bloquer non je peux mettre mon roi là et
pousser parce que lui il me bloque
ça autant près je crois ce que tu dis
euh
il y aura cette roi il veut dire comme
ça sûrement mais
c'était intéressant
[Musique]
si vous voulez bon là il a avancé mais
il faut venir tenir le pion pour faire
roi BK
nul facile
autant prêt nul
mais pas dans la bonne position du tout
fort on en a un instant les gars ou
imaginez même pas après le clics
maintenant je te fais les annonces et tu
vois c'est encore une fois c'est le 2
qui a encore qui encore frappé j'ai joué
un coup et après je suis oh merde ça
marche pas il y a ça en fait à chaque
fois j'arrive à retomber sur mes pattes
donc 300 3 7 3
et
bon ben il laisse vous faire voir avec 4
donc ça va être nul sûrement un peu
penser à ça ça
je sais pas où est-ce qu'on met le roi
si on met là ou là
le risque de perdre quand même façon
genre ça sans peut-être tourgé
et d'avoir la même fille en fait
je suis bête
et sur chaque roi là voilà bon
malheureusement je me lance tout reprend
ok mais ça reste quand même c'est ok
c'est nul mais faut pas se tromper
encore mais c'est plutôt fin de Forest
qui va être en train de qui va te
retrouver les cours on va y arriver en
tout cas on va arriver sur ce genre de
position
ok pour lui donc
3 4 5 6 donc on a la position à peu près
qu'on avait dit le même genre il s'est
passé ça
il a mangé
H5 B3 qui avait les 500
d'ailleurs c'est un coup candidat on l'a
pas vu
s
on n'avait pas forcément évoqué mais il
y a cavalier à 3 comme coup mais il
fallait trouver C4 ça j'avais pas vu moi
j'ai pensé c'était le enfin pas logique
que nous on avait pensé comme le
Cavalier Blanc devra venir ici pour
défendre ces deux
G3 pour défendre ici
on avait dit qu'il y avait du C4 qui
fait du BK
au début j'étais ultra sceptique j'avais
pas compris
la force de l'idée mais par contre
Wesley saut pas mal non plus
prise très belle nulle de combat tu
penses qu'il va prendre non
et donc comment est-ce qu'on joue là
je mange là
OK
dans ce cas-là c'est
[Musique]
pas mal
parce que
il a passé de matos pour gagner en fait
il y a peut-être plus précis mais tout à
l'heure on voyait que
l'ordin n'avait pas trop aimé le cours
autour des 8 de camer mais en fait la
conception était ultra puissante je
pense quand tu l'attends
cette position avec la culture la finale
quoi
un peu tout ça et je trouve ça
assez fort si les éléments c'est
monstrueux
j'adore ce qu'il a fait j'aime bien
aussi
du coup alors Ding contre Aronian donc
il avait ce petit problème aussi c'est
pas de bêtises des noirs
[Musique]
c'est trop fort quoi
et c'est quand même à faire un petit peu
un peu retourné digne parce que il
commence à voir les pièces un peu
bizarres et il a plu autant de jeux que
tout à l'heure
qui va arriver ou même du cavalier 5 qui
peut revenir ici pour attaquer des
quatre
il y a 5 10 coups
de d'armagnon
mais finalement
j'aime bien
faut faire presque attention après c'est
une partie hyper casse-gueule pour les
deux joueurs je pense ça te pose
dès que tu es sert avec un camp tu peux
trouer
on a très tendu vous voyez être
structure déséquilibrée les pièces
blanches bizarres mais en même temps
offensive bon
très très tentant
ok donc si il prend là il y a ça en
l'air
ouais puis il y a toujours le la tour B8
en prime
donc il y a eu ton B4
on en a parlé
c'est très malin parce qu'il a fait à
Nice guéri il ouvre son fût d'abord et
maintenant il joue carré des cartes
je gagne pas une pièce ah bah non parce
que maintenant il a joué ah oui donc
un je peux circuler sur la 4e maintenant
la tour des case maintenant grâce à ces
trois
mais bon
pour mettre un peu de pression
que j'accepte maintenant la finale avec
mon pion réussi
chaleur
ouais c'est
en terme de calcul c'est classe
comme ça sur le fil
il aime bien ses positions
comme ça
je peine encore tu vois à chaque fois
j'aimerais pas jouer ce joueur là je
serais curé je pense à chaque fois il y
a un truc qui se passe et au bout d'un
moment tu es fatigué des ressources
trouvées par l'adversaire honnêtement là
c'est pas si simple
je vois pas le gain clair si tu veux se
dégager sauf j'aimerais bien mais
malheureusement je trouve qu'il défend
comme tu le dis sur le fil et
des fois tu perds pieds même ampli sur
des défenses bien moins bonnes que cela
et là je vois le mec c'est tous les
coups en partie quoi
tu as l'impression qu'il joue un peu
border mais en même temps ça tient à
chaque fois
où je mets
la dame
alors si je vais ici
je tape ici je garde un peu toutes les
entreprises
madame prend ainsi je peux échanger
faire roi B7 peut-être
j'en peux plus tu sais il y a toujours
un truc qui se passe c'est horrible quoi
c'est très très chaud mais faut
il y a toujours tout recap parce qu'au
début derrière le pion ça a l'air bien
mais en fait il y a tout recades quoi
toujours un truc qui se passe dans cette
position
excuse-moi juste de 5
[Musique]
donc les gens ont plus que 10 minutes
chacun avec 9 coups pour arriver au 40e
coups donc là je pense qu'on peut on
peut avoir un petit avec
d'autant plus que tout à l'heure la
position 1 je la trouvais plus facile à
jouer mais dès qu'il a trouvé tour B8
tour B4 et compagnie maintenant je
trouve que les deux positions sont
complexes quoi
alors donc
ça reste assez égal un pract qui joue
hyperactif voyez il a un peu moins mais
je suis très actif ce qui avait les qui
est très fort le Pione qui est une
faiblesse c'est vraiment une chance de
passer là on s'entend quand même à une
nul en fait partie Kevin yes
rapports
de ce qu'on peut voir le foie réussi à
sortir s'activer
donc les pièces séchant qu'elle va les
prendre un prank
peut-être plus G5 pour défendre le pion
H6 une position qui est assez égale
[Musique]
de faire nul aussi cette partie là ouais
je préfère la jouer avec les Blancs
évidemment je
sens un petit peu c'est un petit un
petit plus avec un éventuellement la
création de la pompe à passer sur le
long terme j'ai quand même du matelas à
jouer je trouve qu'elle est un peu
chiante à jouer ce genre de position
typique ou tu sais que c'est égal mais
que tu arrives pas à tenir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
en toute simplicité
avec un renard franchement
il améliore les pièces
66 c'est dire ça veut tout dire
[Musique]
il est quasiment à son plus bas ça fait
longtemps qu'il a été il a pas été aussi
faible et quand on dit ça quelqu'un qui
est 2766 bon ça va il a eu quasiment
toute sa vie de plus de 28 quoi et je
pense que c'est
en termes d'ancienneté dans les 2800 Elo
à part carassen c'est clairement le
numéro 2 parce qu'il était plus
longtemps que Ding par exemple et
[Musique]
de nous chauffer je pense il y a
quelqu'un connaît un site pour miser sur
les matchs mais ça existe
beaucoup avec stouf c'est pour ça que je
dis ça on fait des petits Paris perso
qu'on donne en début de stream et du
coup ouais mais je sais que à un moment
on pourrait le faire sur des grands
sites mais ça existe plus trop quoi bah
il y avait un site alors je vais jamais
su comment il s'appelait
mais il y avait un site anglais je crois
comme bet.com
je vais créer un
t'imagines un truc
mais mais non en fait il y avait un truc
mais après c'est c'est compliqué parce
qu'en fait les le monde des échecs
étaient assez petit tout le monde se
connaît et c'est du 1 contre un et en
fait il peut y avoir des arrangements et
tout en fait du coup c'est compliqué par
exemple je sais pas moi demain je compte
Kevin
on se dit bah tiens on fait nul Kevin et
il a bloqué le nom de domaine et tu as
Kevin si je vous montre moi qui est
blanc avec les noirs et ben il va être
ravi de faire du contre moi parce qu'il
perd tout le temps donc du coup
du coup on va se dire on fait nul et du
coup moi je parie ma maison sur la nul
et en fait ben je sens gagner en fait et
au final c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident
et je crois que c'est le site en
question
il était il y avait beaucoup de sites en
fait sur lequel on enfin beaucoup de
pays qui sont pas accessibles donc soit
il fallait avoir un VPN soit soit dans
un autre pays mais je crois qu'on
l'Europe j'avais essayé parce que moi
j'avais moi j'ai pas de VPN mais j'avais
été dans plusieurs pays donc j'avais été
en Argentine c'était ça marchait pas
franchement plus Espagne non plus elle
était dans tout le monde pour voir sur
quel site on peut comment préparer sur
ce site ça sera dark stouf bet.com
alors si moi je vois je propose-lui du
chat
par contre si là les blancs il a jamais
les Noirs mais blanc
chaque partie se propose enfin je mets
la maison sont nulle sans même que je
peux aller vraiment je vais dormir
tranquille je je vais tapis la maison et
je vais me coucher et le lendemain je
suis sûr de me réveiller que avec deux
maisons quoi c'est sûr donc on dit ouais
ta parole sur tes propres matchs genre
n'importe quel sport on connaît il y
avait cette histoire même au tennis
après il y a des contrôles sur les
personnes qui font des paris arranger
oui en fait c'est toujours pareil mais
il y en a qui triche mieux que d'autres
c'est toujours pareil mais c'est de
toute façon c'est une triche au Paris
c'est pas une triche effective une
triche au Paris donc voilà c'était un
petit délire avant tout hein vous
inquiétez pas
salut à toi poignard et on joue des
tournois en France Kevin et Stef pour ma
part je joue plus que le Top 16
c'est-à-dire la division 1 aux échecs
c'est le seul tournage de fait dans
l'année histoire de m'entretenir de ne
pas vraiment mais c'est juste parce que
j'adore les échecs quand même et que
c'est une belle compétition à jouer du
coup j'ai des mecs comme bakuga sheriri
comme partenaire de de club donc ça fait
bizarre voilà mais en tout cas
[Rires]
j'avais fait un petit donc une petite
vidéo sur sur YouTube sur la chaîne et
ça résumait un petit peu tout il y a le
capitaine d'équipe qui est grand maître
jean-noëlle Rif donc le grand maître
alsacien qui disait bah nous on fait les
donc les Indiens jouent sur les trois
premiers échiquier nous on leur fait les
crêpes le matin trouvez que c'était
assez génial quoi donc il faisait des la
seule demande de de nos joueurs indiens
c'était d'avoir des crêpes le matin
voilà ils sont pas hyper exigeants je
peux te dire du coup c'était c'était
quand même c'est bon et du coup lui il
faisait les crêpes pour les joueurs
indiens ouais faut qu'il soit en forme
faut qu'ils aient leurs crêpes voilà
c'était bon donc
j'avais vu une vidéo d'ailleurs de
Jean-Noël faire des crêpes
était-ce
des mangeurs de crêpes qui jouent bien
aux échecs
alors attends Carlson on va voir un peu
45 ce qui se passe je vais mettre la
caméra
et tant que parapluie incroyable
il y a pas trop le choix dans cette
ligne là à partir du moment où tu fais
tour G7 tu as vu la préférée vent de
Forest celle-là
il avait très vite moi je demande je
pense que maintenant il va trouver mais
à se demander pourquoi il a calculé
aussi vite c'est possible tu me diras
mais
c'est bizarre que du coup il
réfléchissent tu vois ce stuff
je sais pas il a pas l'air
il vérifie quoi
ce parapluie que que nous on a trouvé
tempo et ben on va être joué ici
c'est beau c'est sympa le petit le petit
coup donc le parapluie c'est d'être
protégé par un pion adverse
pour laisser filer son pion on va
remonter si je fais ça pour les effacer
le pions bah le problème en fait c'est
qu'il y a tout reprend G5 qui fait échec
et qui va dévier ma tour qui empêchait
du coup le pion d'avancer et du coup bah
si je mange là-bas voilà et là je perds
et du coup l'idée de faire G4 c'est que
sur tout reprendre et ben je mange
champion et maintenant manger des
chances de pouvoir essayer de passer
confiance et s'il prend du pion ici et
bah du coup maintenant et ben il a plus
de tout reprendre échec comme il avait
avant et après ranger 2 Les Bains ils la
tour peut pas empêcher mon roi en fait
de partir quoi en fait c'est assez
simple de pousser le pion le problème
c'est que bien sûr en faisant ça va ça
crée aussi blanc donc là ça va être la
course et tout à l'heure on l'a calculé
on a vu que ça faisait nuit là donc
il a calculé il avait du coup tout
anticipé vers une grande forêt c'est pas
très dur pour lui
ça va faire nuit normalement c'est assez
ça a l'air assez assez en fait
reprise c'était quoi le problème
il a eu peur de cavaliers des deux
peut-être
où est-ce qu'on pouvait imaginer parce
que tu as toujours ton pion B qui est
très intéressant quoi
et là et en fait il a dû vouloir prouver
une conception presque pour jouer parce
que cavalier B1 ça avait l'air d'être
le petit kumana il a oublié quelque
chose sans doute
je pense qu'il a vu B3 x 5 ou C3 il veut
gagner quoi
et B2 quoi un truc comme ça mais bon
a gagné l'iface merci on va aller voir
mais bon on s'y attendait honnêtement
parce que il a fait une énorme partie
ah oui en fait ça marche pas du tout
roi des trois
B2
c'est dommage pour Kemer il avait fait
une super partie la conception était
super bien il a vraiment gaffé trois
j'ai [ __ ] en cavalier prend et là
en fait
on a la jauge on a vu qu'il y avait eu
des scouts
comme quoi vous voyez comme c'est dur
les échecs sur un coup on peut bazarder
très vite une position et du coup sur ça
[Musique]
sans il faut du coup je vais ça d'abord
surprise prise je mange là et c'est moi
qui vais je vais gagner et B2 à 5
jusqu'à plus quand et sur ça ça et si on
prend calculer que le cavalier est un
peu trop loin je peux même taré à chaque
si on veut
en fait il revient quand même je reviens
quand même mais peut-être que j'ai des
chances du coup comment je passe
cette histoire tu veux juste faire ça ça
[Rires]
la démonstration on aurait dû aller un
peu moins vite je pense qu'on a on a été
un peu trop vite j'étais c'est moi qui
t'ai influencé
ou un truc du genre
ou un je sais pas parce que là pour pas
laisser des chèques c'est pas oui sur ça
il y a ça ah c'est beaucoup mieux c'est
plus professionnel
je laisse comme ça je le ferai plus tard
ouais déjà ouais c'est plus
professionnel
avant le rajout de temps
on va voir un peu ce qui va se passer on
peut aller voir ce qui s'est passé du
coup avec rapport et apparemment on
avait dit que ça avait l'air quand même
assez égale c'est carrément égal
maintenant
il y a eu des échanges ah oui il a
réussi à liquider carrément la totale là
ok ok
nul
car
Google
on avait annoncé pour l'instant on a
deux sur deux au pronostic
ouais mais on avait vu on avait vu les
mêmes donc
du coup mais on est bon là on est bon
OK et du coup par rapport à un enfant de
stick voilà il y a cette finale là qui
risque de faire nul en fait que moi
j'avais dit à zéro
et à celle-là du coup qui est
intéressant pour toi ou tu avais annoncé
1-0 donc on avait pas vu depuis
longtemps ça a vraiment beaucoup pé le
volume en fait
[Musique]
beaucoup de choses
donc il y a eu la fameuse décision
d'arme prend des 5 là on galérait pour
trouver un autre coup de toute façon
tourbé 2 qu'on avait annoncé aussi je
crois donc là ils te font pas son
cavalier mais en fait il prépare une
petite porte de sortie pour son roi
voilà
qui peut être compliqué
mais même celle-là aussi avec des C2
c'est compliqué les rois je vais préfère
garder c'est surtout quand j'ai 3 on
prend j'ai trois et moi et puis actif en
fait quand je viens
tourné deux là c'est hyper chaud en
prison
qui après échecs logique et maintenant
ça fait nul
franchement c'est ouf parce que quand tu
vois la partie mais ça fait plusieurs
parties en fait comme ça
que à chaque fois enfin très souvent en
fait et ben il a dit
tu le vois vraiment frôler la limite
tu vois
genre hier contre hier contre dinghyrain
il était archi perdant il a réussi à
faire nul et je veux vraiment que le feu
je veux vraiment que le feu irrigazi et
il fait nul quoi enfin tu vois il perd
pas quoi mais depuis le début c'est
parti c'est vraiment très très
borderling à chaque fois
donc un tout petit peu attention ici
parce qu'il a le droit loin
il est aiguisé
en tout cas Magnus sa petite finale mine
de rien
bon on dirige je pense que je pourrais
du coup il y a que moi qui peut gagner
le pari s'il m'a compris
[Musique]
un petit motif je trouve enfin il
travaille un petit peu quoi
tant des choses on va voir donc on a
encore des parties intéressantes à
suivre j'ai trouvé les parties hyper
qualitatives là les joueurs sont chauds
parce qu'il y avait eu des trucs un peu
plus bizarroïdes tu vois dans les
parties enfin après c'est que tu as plus
vues que moi mais je trouve que la
partie du jour
c'est peut-être goûté qui a été un petit
peu en dessous parce que même si erwana
a bien joué
mais sinon on sauvegamer c'était hyper
fort digne à rognan c'est une super
partie guérir c'est juste fou
c'était pas une mauvaise partie du tout
contre
il y avait pas beaucoup de déchets
aujourd'hui non
et du beau combat après si vous êtes
parti que vous voulez voir vous avez des
questions ou quoi que soit n'hésitez pas
ça peut me mettre des parties qui est
dans le dans le le
challenger nous on n'a pas trop regardé
challenger mais s'il y a des choses des
des grosses grosses parties qui se
passent en direct n'hésitez pas à nous à
nous
nous faire part en tout cas c'est
spectacle
Guiri quand même contre yasie qui sonne
pas la nul mais c'était une très grosse
partie en tout cas donc je t'envoie la
regarder en tout cas belle partie c'est
un préféré je pense et aussi de gamer
contre saut qui malheureusement
a complètement
craqué dans la fin de partie gamer mais
il a fait un sacrifice de pions qui
était très très sympa
un magnifique cette
le roi j'avais mis
un poil différent
et du coup c'est un peu la même ité non
ici je dois pouvoir faire peut-être
reprendre la carte 5 ou 5 directement
mais j'ai pas besoin je fais E5 comme tu
l'as dit c'est plus c'est plus safe
je peux aussi pousser là mais là il va
falloir
parce que si je prends la tête
va partir là-haut mais le temps qu'il
fasse une dame
je suis déjà là quoi
[Musique]
de scène qui qui va faire un humain
on y est
et bien sûr les deux joueurs sont
concentrés mais on va arriver vite à la
nul
je peux mettre du coup là
la partie Dany chariot c'était une
Merrant et c'est hyper chaud
la coupe Charles Henri j'appelle ça la
Couchard Henri la coupe Mozart
qui secoue la tête
c'est cool la tête apparemment rien ne
marche je crois
que rien ne marche ici
le Mozart des échecs ça lui va bien bah
voilà
bon et puis bon ça position ouais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut aller voir qui
était un peu plus croustillant est-ce
que Vincent Kemer s'en est sorti et je
pense pas d'ailleurs souffre je connais
la réponse quoi
il y a pas de
et digne à rognon peut-être ce qui est
encore un designer ou pas
parce que 36e coup avec deux minutes
la caméra du coup sur sur ce genre là
[Musique]
en grand comme ça
vu que c'est de voir un petit peu les
joueurs
donc Ding qui a une qui a trois minutes
contre une minute 30 pour jouer encore
trois coups
mais bon il cherche il cherche il
cherche il sait pas forcément
ma caméra qui est encore sauté
il vérifie si vous voulez il a pas non
plus réfléchi une demi-heure
même alors niveau ça peut arriver de
rater quelque chose il doit estimer que
Jordan van forest il a du bol que à un
temps prêt la finale face nulle il y a
tout cet aspect là qui peut rentrer en
ligne de compte
donc ça reste des réflexions assez
limitées quand même
cette position elle a un petit peu
chaude tour des seins la seule partie
qui est pas encore vraiment décidé parce
qu'on a l'impression que Carlson ça va
faire nul que sauver il va gagner que
Kiri et ça fait un nul et que
Abdou prak ça veut faire nul aussi donc
ça c'est la seule partie digne contrat
aronia je pense
qui qui joue encore et on sait pas
vraiment encore ce qui ce qui se passe
et ça peut vite en plus
[Musique]
se calmer ce genre de position
pas avec H1 Candice
je vais mettre le carillon
il peut lancer 5 et en E5
rigolo
dès que je t'aime à cause de toutes les
caméras il faut
je veux pas que la caméra
disparaisse plein de petits trucs à
faire
du coup H5 qui fixe un petit peu la
structure
qui prépare éventuellement une case pour
le cavalier
39 secondes faut pas il lui reste deux
coups donc c'est rien mais
position casse-gueule
donc les joueurs savent très bien ce
qu'ils font ils ont l'habitude de noter
des coups même avec très peu de temps la
pendule je vois pas qu'ils sont quand
même 30 secondes par coup
donc ça ça va
mais il faut noter c'est important c'est
obligatoire
sauf dans les cadences où il y a moins
de 30 secondes parcours quand tu arrives
à moi je voulais faire l'inverse je
voulais faire cavalier 5 et proposer G4
OK
donc il va faire l'inverse donc
l'idée 6 cavaliers 5
avec des histoires de cavaliers G6
les petites
c'est bien vu juste pour le Zino
là il va avoir du mal à jouer son cou
grosse pression au temps
de craquer
à rognon parce que c'était des positions
qui sont pas faciles
doit être très content parce que
maintenant il a un bon pressing alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait KFC ou cavalier E5
ça force tourner
je pense pas que ça marche
ça m'a l'air un peu trop trop
bourrin je sais pas
comment regarder avec cavalier
5 ça évite cavalier E5 en fait
ça vite tu reprends le 5 mais est-ce que
ça marche et tu reprends est-ce qu'on
peut voir s'il te plaît l'histoire parce
que maintenant qu'il a remarque après
les anecdotes peut-être
et c'est le bordel clairement il y a le
pion qui
risque de d'éclater jusqu'à ce qui se
passe
non attendre règle le 3 donc ça c'est
très risqué